it is Wednesday that means get out your
notebook get out your pens get out your
paper get out your reading glasses cuz
you're about to be in school sim school
he studies the film teaches you the
lessons you need to learn and then you
so giddy
ain't that right professor sit that's
right listen to what I say or you will
pay down by the bay in about three or
four minutes we are gonna have Michael
Lombardi good friend of yours yes and
also a guy that's been all over the NFL
we're gonna get to talk to him about
some of these Patriots things that are
going on whether it's Josh Gordon or the
new book that's coming out that's about
Brady and Belichick we'll talk about
Tomlin and McDaniels versus Patricia a
little bit later on we got Phil Simms
and I got a DM here about little parties
that used to happen in his Franklin
Lakes house can't wait to ask him about
that he throwing the parties and they
talking about me no no no I think it may
have been Dierdre
and then you Doven the Packers Vikings
bucks Eagles dolphins Jets a little
Broncos Raiders a little Colts little
Washington got a little film study Maria
got panthers and falcons some what all
that's not as deep as I'd like but if we
got enough of it and of course you know
those little birdies sheep chirping in
my ear
Atlanta Superbowl probably should get
down there if you like Sims left go are
you gonna talk about this every week
it's kind of fun kind of like some stuff
before we get Michael and Barney on the
line just some transactions and things
Tom Johnson back with the Vikings good
so now they have Sheldon Richardson and
Tom Johnson apparently yeah some Vikings
fans refer to Tom Johnson as Sebastian
thunder buckets because there was the
belief that he was really good and no
one talked about it right and it's
because he had a boring name so they
call him Sebastian thunder bucket gotta
size it up you're like thunder bucket
with the sack you're like now I like
this I wonder what happened with him in
Seattle I just don't get it
you Seattle needs defensive linemen to
definitely do Andy Levite Ray out for
the Falcons for the season on IR how big
is it that he they lose him at guard you
know I I thought it was gonna be a big
deal I really did but then watching the
the game on film a little bit and seeing
I gotta say his name the right way she
white sir yes west Schweitzer he did a
pretty good job well he's been on there
before I know saw him you know that's
good when they're used to the system and
that there's no doubt it's not a shock
and the Fusco is pretty good he is hate
me playing better than I really ever
gave him credit for he's probably pretty
good football right now
Darius slay concussion we'll see if he
plays Sunday night
Cowboys getting Randy Gregory and Xavier
woods back how big of a deal is Xavier
woods at safety I mean it is a big deal
he heard Jerry Jones came out and say
nobody was playing better this offseason
than Xavier well he was pretty awesome
in the preseason especially the game he
got hurt in he's he is again we got to
think about this it's almost like the
Seattle scheme a little bit and he can
be that Earl Thomas type of guy he can
fly around the field he is fearless as a
hitter and you know really low left go
at the end of the day their secondary is
pretty legit right now already they are
I mean I don't I don't have too many
questions about it I'm not worried about
legality its them figuring it on offense
to make us not look stupid at the East
bed right alright whenever you're ready
give a call on a Micah Lombardi do you
see Minka Fitzpatrick filed a trademark
for fits magic look but what like two
days later after if it's magic did it no
Fitz no Minka is the only one that has a
trademark in right now is that right I
thought I heard Fitz magic tried to do
this laughing we can't call him Fitz
magic if they're both going after if
it's magic but but I this actually made
like I love Minka Fitzpatrick right like
come on there's one Fitz magic all right
all right a mink I don't know wait hold
on I got to see this no see wait yep
you're right oh yeah Minka yeah the only
one in there with a Fitz magic trademark
request wow that's cool he's been ballin
I know that he is something of the
better career but I don't know if that's
Fitz Matt I know I don't think a DB can
ever be Fitz magic I know that I mean
that's just you know what that sound is
what that is the sultry static behind a
man that has been in the front office
with legends and he himself drops more
gems than Robin Hood after a little
thievery
yes that's Michael Lombardo how you
doing Mike I'm doing good thank you how
are you you know I'd be better if I had
a
copy of gridiron genius a master class
of winning championships and building
guys in the NFL but I'll buy I'll buy
the book man you can buy all Amazon it
they are grandkids I you know it's hard
you know this is all new to me I have no
idea how this all works but it's a good
book you should read it
I'm 100% going to hey how you doing I'm
your friend Chris Sims you remember me I
know who Chris Simms is yeah the great
Christians yes I loved watching him on
Saturday afternoon yes I get all my
knowledge I jot it all down trust me I
write it down oh thank you I appreciate
that
I don't know if I believe you there but
also hey he's got grandkids and this is
the best part of his grandkid all right
so Mike's son works for the jet yes he
had a son he he has had a son but this
is Mick Lombardi who was a quarterback
coach of the Jets this is how awesome
Mike is though my granddad's a granddad
he refers to his grandson as baby Jesus
really yes
because he's living that privileged life
and I'm sure the family's always talking
about them so this is where Mike I get
such a kick out of you saying that man
is the first one he's just bad and you
know and I got another one down at
bruton for the Baylor Bears down at Waco
so it's been a good life I'm looking
forward to being a grandfather for a
long long time that's where I got to
write the book I got to keep keep
writing I got a supportable that's
awesome well I'm excited look the book
dives into Belichick and and Al Davis
and and really everywhere you've been
that's incredible my dad has read it
you're mad regionally Mike gave him a
book you're not on my dad's level yeah
so he got a book no I gave him a galley
copy of the book well this is I don't
know if Mike knows this so dad got about
three quarters away through the book
were on our trip out to a Yellowstone
National Park
he's reading it while we're out there he
left it when we left there so he didn't
have it on the plane all he did was
complain in the play ride no Donna did
you pick up my book he's like a 12 year
old stuff lifted by the nightstand so
then he had to go to the store and buy
one anyway
gridiron genius so good that phil simms
will complain on an entire airplane ride
back that he's lost it yes well I've
been fortunate enough to be around film
you know to do when we
inside the NFL on Showtime so he's
probably heard all the stories he was
just refreshing his memory there that's
all
so it was it I'm happy he read it I
really was I was hoping he would read it
to Christopher I was disappointed I
haven't ever ready yeah yeah I know I
know Chris Sims has read one book in his
entire life it's like JFK conspiracy
book like Mike that's for me too I've
got a bunch of those books here in my
house I've read everything there is to
read about JFK's conspiracy I've got
everything to read about Oswald did it
alone so you know I I'm something since
some days I'm not very similar we're
gonna have to do maybe an entire episode
one time of you guys breaking down the
JFK assassination but for right now Mike
I listened to your podcast ringer NFL
show I don't know if it used to be
called GM Street but you always have
such great stuff GM Street it's great
and three yeah it's the second best NFL
podcast I've heard behind left go I'm
just kidding
Josh Gordon you were saying on your
broad the truth is we want it more for
Josh Gordon than Josh Gordon wants it
for himself that he doesn't love
football and I was like wow that's a
really good insight bail checks coming
out today and saying look it's not
finalized I'm curious from the GM
perspective when the Browns go out there
and go we're cutting them and then they
start fielding calls I imagine it's like
one of those old-school videos of
somebody connecting phone lines being
like we got the Patriots on line two
they want to fit around pic hey the Pats
are also offering us a five do you want
a fourth how do how does that happen
like what were the Browns doing in terms
like Dorsey fielding calls well I think
look they leaked it out there they're
gonna cut them so they could generate
interest so they don't have to go around
it and you know and certainly it's like
an advertisement it's a billboard
basically you know it's the best thing
you can do and it gives you gives teams
two days especially after a game Monday
morning everybody's sitting there after
they lost always thinking about how can
they improve their team so it makes it
easier to announce it to the media that
you're gonna trade the guy or cut the
guy one way or the other I mean I don't
think the Browns were hiding behind
anything look what I said on my podcast
I believe to be true I know there were
ten teams
called but the Patriots got the guy for
a fifth and they're getting back to
sevens if the guy doesn't play their hat
there could not have been a lot of teams
making offers right like if if the
Patriots if somebody would have offered
say San Francisco would have offered
their 6a firm or their 6f seeps active
for five that's better than the Patriot
deal because at least a six is at the
top of the round the Patriots at the
bottom of the fifth you know you still
you don't have to kick back anything so
to me it didn't seem like as much as
people wanted to put their toe in the
water and see how it felt for Josh
Gordon I don't get the sense that they
actually wanted to go swimming and and
you think that just because they don't
want to risk anything to deal with him
do you think teams know about you know
how you say you're not sure he really
loves the game of football like what
what late what leads teams to call and
then chickened out maybe per se and New
England not to chicken out and actually
go through with it
well no anyone went through with it but
but it really in the end of the day
Christopher they're out there they're
their liability is they traded a fifth
47th yeah basically so I don't think
they see much liability here I think the
other teams are dealing with the unknown
and the Patriots are dealing with the
unknown nobody really knows like nobody
really knows what they're getting nobody
knows what happened at a promotional
thing nobody knows if he's going back
and had some problems if he stubbed his
toe off the field nobody really knows
nobody knows what kind of shape he's in
because he's a different human being yes
than he was in 2013 he's much bigger you
don't know what kind of shape he's in
you don't know how he's going to adapt
it there's so many unknowns that I think
but you know it starts towei on it and
for the Patriots to me this is a trade
like you know their offense is stagnant
they're not explosive so they've added a
legitimate 3-point shooter
you've got to go to send them at the
line and it'll open up some other things
for guys to drive down the paint which
is what they need but in the in the
short term you got to go out and defend
Josh Gord you got to go to seven
three-point line somebody's got to go
out there and handle them and if you
don't there'll be some way he'll get it
down the field they hope that was
Patterson but that hasn't really worked
out right that's where I love your
basketball analogies because they
metaphor my Clemente
that's what Lefko calls you metaphor
Mike but your you are amazing that way
but yeah alright so I just threw out
this theory do you think all the things
you said about Josh Gordon of course and
how it how it pertains to New England
and why they need him and defending the
3-point shot but do you think this is
something where bill gets done with
Jacksonville on Sunday afternoon and
goes damn like we can't beat this team
later on drive down the playoffs
whatever it may be if we don't get
another weapon to open up the court or
open up the field like you're saying I
think I think he's been having this
conversation with himself all spring all
summer I think they would have made 28
or 27 transactions if they thought they
had it I think this has been a problem
look there could be a documentary it
probably would have to be three parts a
3434 three hours on why the Patriots
can't solve their wide receiver problems
yes because it's it's it's just no team
has done it whereas Pittsburgh you know
hit pick a receiver and next thing you
know they've got a really good player
yes you know Brandon cooks looks way
better in Los Angeles in the first two
weeks that he did really plain for the
England he was a good player for doing
the question receiver right you know so
and then Robert Woods was to me a very
average receiver and Buffalo goes out to
the Rams it looks completely different
so there's a documentary somewhere in
this about why the Patriots and
receivers have been so inconsistent and
I think a lot of it goes back to when
you just look at Danny Marino and you
look at what he was there and the
veterans that you have when you have a
quarterback who's played as long as
Brady
yes and the PlayBook has to keep up with
them right it affects younger players
it affects development of younger
players I'm not making excuses for the
Patriots yeah it does it affects it yes
you know and so therefore they can't
learn it and Brady's dealing with an
offense that he's been around for 18
years and some new kid coming in you
know from Georgia let's say you know
this is all foreign to him it's hard
it's hard to get young players into the
Patriots system to play right away at
skill yeah really yeah that's that's a
fascinating point and you're exactly
right because I've been having those
conversations even with my father about
Brandon cooks you know just why does he
look so much better in Los Angeles and
it's not like the Patriots
know how to use receivers it's just I
don't know I kind of chalked it up with
the Rams is just they know how to use a
guy like that they shun McVeigh's
awesome and just getting one like a Kyle
Shanahan I'm gonna get one guy off and
use him so many different ways that then
you're gonna have to use resources on
defense to stop him and then everybody
else can be that jumping off spot but I
feel like New England hasn't been able
to do that other than for maybe Grunk
here you know the last few years yeah
and look rocks great there's no doubt
rocks great but Rock is well if Gronk is
a build the speed down the field got
he's been in and out quickness guy so he
needs the field to be open he needs to
run scenes and in cuts and you know it
takes him a while to get that big body
moving right and so you know Hernandez
was the quicker guy Hernandez was they
were the perfect combination you know
and so now James White's that quick guy
to go with Bronk inside but James why
can't run the ball after he catches it
James White's a catcher he's not a
runner he's a catcher and so he can't
really do that much after the catch he
goes down instantly but going back to
the Rams I think it's deeper than just
play design I think it's fundamentals
and techniques I think they do an
unbelievable job of teaching routes and
I think they win because of the
attention to detail on their route yeah
so good that they're able to get it
communicated you know we just take
receivers running routes for granted but
they do a great job with conditioning of
their receivers they do a great job of
fundamentals with their receivers
they've had no drops this year as a
football team okay they don't even say
catch the ball Robert what's made a
catch last week that gothram
two feet behind them that motion that
Robin Woods was still in Buffalo there's
no chance he's making that catch right
but he did last week mmm all right so I
mean mcveigh's up there at the best
o'seas in the game with Kyle with Sean
Payton and undoubtedly with Josh
McDaniels right we always try to explain
to people how good Josh is Sunday night
he's facing off against Matt Patricia
and these were both guys that were
battling for a long time about who's
gonna replace Bill this is me personally
McDaniels is a is a guy that we're gonna
look back in a few decades and go wow
one of the best play callers and I think
Patricia Mike is one of those guys that
I've always thought it's Belichick
do you think the McDaniel
is gonna dial it up a little bit more
for Patricia on Sunday night
well they practiced against each other
for how many years right Matt's been
there calling the defense since 12 yeah
so I mean you know and Josh went back in
13 so I mean they've had these battles
back and forth Josh knows how Matt
Thanks you know Matt was always going to
blitz during OTAs and and mini camps but
when the games were going when he was
going to be more conservative so I don't
know where josh is thinking he's going
to go in this game but the Lions have
its plays out with the concussion which
I'm sure you probably will be because
he's in the protocol you know it's gonna
limit what they can do and you know the
weapons that the Patriots have are not
great but they're good enough to get
open against Detroit they're gonna have
to manage Ziggy Anzu if he plays right
you did last week you know so they're
gonna have to handle that situate it in
last week so they gotta handle that they
got to take an throughout the game and
then the sky's the limit but I agree
with you Josh will nominate this matchup
you do yeah you think yeah I mean what
do you find in usually in just history
in situations like this do you think the
offensive guy or defensive guy has the
advantage in this type of situation I
think the offensive guy has because he's
going first and he can move the pieces
around and he knows last defense better
than that noses defend right and so
whenever that's what makes Kyle's so
good that's what makes Shawn McBay so
good that's what makes Sean Payton so
good yes is they know the defense and I
wrote about it in my book look bill
Walsh's genius is the fact that he
coached defensive backs account he under
started to understand how defenses are
taught there was a drought the other day
that against the Raiders that that cup
Cooper Cup ran and he hesitated for a
minute he stayed inside right and he
went to the flat knee caught the
touchdown pass now that route right
there is all you need to know about
McVeigh understanding the coverages if
cup would have gone to the flat right
away the attacker would have them right
now he has first a flat
right because cup stayed inside the
backer did to see first the flat so he
froze right and cup waited and then he
went to the flat and by the time he went
to the flat the linebacker was like Fred
Flintstone he couldn't get his feet
moving fast enough to get the car going
so he was on a walk yeah that's a great
point we talk about it a lot I mean yes
Kyle and McVeigh Shawn paid naked they
could be defensive coordinator and you
talked about Kyle
used to sit in defensive meeting with
Monte Kiffin and Rod Marinelli and Mike
Tomlin and Tampa he would sit there he
wanted to hear them teach the defense
right so he could come back and screw
them over at some point and then and he
did last week with maybe last week with
with you know he pulled the same thing
yeah a different way you know he put the
back in it but he put the receiver in
the backfield and he create and you know
it caught Matt all off-guard you know
and look I think if there's one
criticism of the Patriots in the Super
Bowl last year's once the quarterback
got out of the pocket and started moving
around a more veteran team with a call
timeout right there like timeout hold on
we're not doing this right you know and
you're not getting away with this place
you leave if the quarterback leaves the
thing call timeout yeah you know and so
they didn't do it and it cost them yeah
you know the other just want I just is
just one another quick one on the
subject but with that I mean I always
found it fascinating and you could give
us a deeper look than anybody bill I
feel like is the vice versa of that
right starts this seven it starts the
80s he's got to defend Bill Walsh in the
San Francisco 49ers so he made it like
his life mission to go I need to
understand this West Coast offense and I
joke around on the show here sometimes
where I go I bet you bill could go up to
Green Bay and teach Michael McCarthy
schemes in the West Coast offense that
he doesn't even have it as offense that
you know just jokingly but I'm actually
kind of serious about it's most of these
guys that are running the West Coast
offense don't understand the origin of
the West Coast often yes that's why the
protections are so bad yeah that's why
you see in free runners coming left and
right trying to block on Miller or
something like that but you know it's
everybody wants to say they know the
West Coast but they don't understand the
origin of how the play was designed and
developed and the mad scientist Bob
McKittrick was able to tie it all
together in San Francisco and there
aren't a lot of Bob mckittridge around
right so we're talking about this
culture and we talk about Bill Belichick
and how it's so refined and after almost
two decades it's a machine now but
everyone's wondered this for the last
decade mike tomlin he is an emotional
guy he can look his players in the eye
he got it from Gruden the Bucks and it
continued through and he really gets
sometimes the best of his players but
sometimes the worst and I'm just curious
you've been a
some of the best cultures how do you
view the Tomlin Pittsburgh culture and
what we're seeing right now well I think
look their attention to details lacking
it's always been lacking I mean you know
they have over 200 yards of penalties
this season already I mean you can't win
games like that you can't turn the ball
over at the rate they turn the ball over
there's too many details last week you
know it's a play that goes unnoticed
earlier in the game this Jones down
seven they couldn't stop them it's third
and nine Ben throws a fade outside you
can't run that play we got to have a
better play on 39 against a really bad
defense right you know cuz if we get
this ball back to him we're down 40
nothing cuz we're not stopping anybody
and so the attention to detail on
Pittsburgh special teams on Pittsburgh's
defense and on their offense is
problematic you know they don't have lay
beyond builder 30% past the 30% run in
the first half and 70% pass and the
Steelers
they fired Todd Haley because he was too
much pass right that's hilarious so
there's it's kind of comical how it's
going back it's not as comical as the
New York Giants draft them say Quan
Barclay in the first round and then
being 31% passed in the first half and
70 in the 31% run and 70 pass in the
first half I mean and then it's not as
comical as the Giants not be able to get
more than three yards on the first down
carry I mean that's more comical that is
that's another subject alright so but
going back to that with the Pittsburgh
thing too because I do think like okay
the attention to detail you're right
it's hard to deny like you would like
somebody to bump their or disrupt seam
routes when you have a flame thrower
like Patrick mahomes who you know is
gonna throw seam routes and you're
expecting your outside corner to steal
the seam routes and cover three and all
that so I totally hear what you're
saying
Tomlin III guess there's part of me that
wants to defend him and go Pittsburgh
has been good too because of that
renegade style but I guess at the end of
the day what I'm asking you here is has
there ever been a team that you can
think of in history that was that
renegade style that actually could win
the Super Bowl or the detailed team's
win Super Bowls bottom line you know and
I mean I know I'm same look in my book
but I think this is a really important
part here yeah back in the 60s you know
when football was you know sixties and
seventies
was really the players right it was it
was talent and how Davis understood it
better than anybody it was you know
schemes were very simplistic the
quarterback called the game at the line
of scrimmage right in Hollywood you know
back then it was always about the actors
and then Robert Evans and I write about
this in my book he decides to start
hiring really good screenwriters and
really good writers and taking movies
and turning her Linda because paramount
was going broke so we changed the
dynamic of Hollywood when NFL changed
the dynamic at it became more of a
scheme and now schemes are so important
they make the players better you still
need great talent but the gaps closed
and those details become so much more
important if you don't cover those
details you're out you're gonna lose key
games against great coaches
you're gonna lose key games against
other people if you go play the Rams and
Wade Phillips Sandeep that's it you
don't have your details lined up they're
gonna get you right and that's what
happens and so Evans made paramount
successful because change the dynamic of
where it was it became the writers not
the actors what and I think that's the
same thing what did Evans do what movies
what is oh you could name a mall you
love story you go through a mall I mean
he started buying books he started
buying books people thought he was crazy
and he started buying books and all
these books turned out to be hit and he
and they turned it and The Godfather was
one of the books he bought and so he
buys them and paramount becomes goes out
of bankruptcy before people were buying
actors that's the analogy here people
are burying actors if you put this actor
in a movie people are going to come see
it he went the other way if the screen
is really good we'll take out Pacino
who's nobody and turn it into a star
follow me yeah I got you so that's
what's happening at the end of same
thing happened in the NFL these schemes
are so complex right now and if you
don't have attention to detail you're
not going to be able to handle it all
right right mark do you have time for
one more question yeah I got plenty of
time okay yeah I'm working on my notes
perfect his book again gridiron genius a
master class and winning championships
and building dynasties in the NFL join
me and buy it on Amazon I'm not gonna be
friends yet but I'll be buying it on
Amazon there's another book that's
coming out don't buy it yet by Mike's
book but this other book I guess he and
O'Connor
Bella check it's got it's got one nugget
in there that Sims has been saying
forever that all Boston fans think that
he is a complete Brady hater and now I
got this nugget and I want to share need
both of your takes Wow
okay is a New England assistant said the
general feeling is that if you gave
Bella cheque in New England any of the
top 15 quarterbacks they could win the
Super Bowl quote I don't think the
coaches view Tom as special as everyone
else in football does mr. Kraft thinks
Tom is the greatest gift ever but the
coaches don't you have said this before
Sims I have never heard Mike talk about
this yeah but it's that the story right
now is Brady versus Belichick and the
ego of this seems to be an issue right
IIIi don't agree with it I think you
know I've been in those meetings I think
people understand I think they're
there's always players are viewed as
even as great as Thomas there's a couple
things he could always do better but the
reality of it is is I think that both
Brady and Belichick are good for one
another and their competitive spirits
drives one another I don't see it that
way
I you know Connor sent me an email last
October asked me to to talk about the
book and I told him I said look I'm
write my own book I have no interest in
helping you know write your book you
know what I'm saying I'm writing my book
so I don't know what's in the book I
have no idea but I just know from being
in meetings well tom is a great player
Tom smart the things Tom does at the
line nobody else can really do and get
into protections and change and
Belichick smart enough to recognize that
he understands it he got five Super Bowl
rings I mean let's face it there could
have been more rings on their fingers
two games to catch that the two games
against the Giants their defense let him
down on the last Drive and really
frankly when you break it down last year
they couldn't stop the Eagles that was a
big 12 game right mean I talked to a
coach after the Super Bowl and he called
me up five minutes after what happened
you know I think 613 yards or 26 minutes
and lost right so you know they couldn't
easily have eight Super Bowls and you
could say well they could have lost the
Carolina they could lost this yeah yeah
they could have lost to those games too
but I think the combination of these two
men work really well together yeah I
hear that I mean there's a hard to deny
I am on more of the side of course hey I
think Brady's awesome but everybody
thinks I hate Brady cuz I don't say he's
the greatest of all time I say Aaron
Rodgers
so just because that statement I say
that but I just I say it more or not
than anything to just say if you broke
down offenses right and you just look at
the overall schemes of what New England
does and then we sit there and watch a
Rodgers in Green Bay or some other teams
that are out there that also have
talented quarterbacks I just go man New
England is playing chess and Aaron
Rodgers is sitting over there they're
playing with like Tyco toys over there I
don't know what the hell they're playing
so that's that I do think there's some
there's some of that I think I think
part of the reason that Aaron Rodgers
has to do that is because it's a
Thompson not because of Mike McCarthy
right because Thompson's belief was
always we're going to get a bunch of
young players in here I'm not going to
find any free agents we're going to be
very young infant to be very young you
got to be very simplistic and if you're
simplistic it's a problem yeah and that
and the Patriots are not simplistic
whatsoever so you got to be very
simplistic and so that to me was a
Carlton Effect era
I think Aaron Rodgers is great I think
he's tremendous but Brady at the line of
scrimmage is remarkable and what he can
do and what he can offer and how he's
been able to play it 41 years old I mean
look in 2013 when I went when I left the
brown or 14 when I left I went to do
anyone Thomas coming off one of his
worst seasons he wasn't playing well
right and you know he wasn't throwing
the ball he's actually thrown the ball
better since then and he did earlier
earlier in that part so yeah I talked
about that a lot I don't see that I
don't see that story yeah okay that's
cool yeah I know we talked about we've
talked about that little period a lot
that's where I get a lot of flack
because I was working there in 2012 and
he wasn't playing that well with
throwing the ball that well and yeah I
was there to recognize it but he is he's
better thrower now he's more like the
Tom Brady in 2006-2007 now and so much
farther along than the 2010 1112 Brady
that you know of course I was studying
and watching a whole lot of write and I
and I think look I think they missed er
Lewis I think they're missing on Louis
badly I don't think they have an
explosive play in the backfield right
and everybody talks about the receivers
but what makes the spread so effective
to the running back you got a defense if
the box is white I mean the Rams are the
pro resemblance you don't defend the box
with a great at the back makes it when
we when we went to the Super Bowl in
2002 with Bill Callahan at the
we had Jerry Rice at the end of his
career we had that tim brown who was
nearing the end of his career
we had Jerry Porter we had rollin
Williams the tight end you couldn't get
any slower than we were but we had
Charlie Gardner in the backfield right
and that made all the difference the
world because Charlie Gardner was an
explosive point guard and he could make
create plays and right now I don't see
that for the Patriots they're true with
birkhead's in there it's not the same
thing Sonny Michonne might be that guy
he's not there yet all right last thing
one more just because this is something
that I like if it's doing to me right
now and we you've kind of talked about
it already and I know it's very early
but I just want to hear you talk because
your mic metaphor but the Jaguars and
the Rams do seem a class above the rest
of the NFL right now like when I watch
the the encouraging thing about like the
Rams is they don't mess around with
teams like on Sunday with the Arizona
Cardinals they just steamroll them
they're like we're better than you were
attack and get out of our way do you
feel that way I know there's a lot of
football left I'm just saying I feel
like they're in a little bit of the
class of their own right now oh I do I
think there's so much better I think
they drive it because they're all
offense drives it I mean they're never
they take don't take the foot off the
gas and if you're a better and they have
a line you know it like this week what
is it 7 points or something you know the
it's they're going to keep trying to
score it where's Jacksonville I think
what you saw in a bortles last week
might be the anomaly right so like
Jacksonville struggled to beat Tennessee
like on paper there should be like no
contest yes right but then when you go
back he's two and four against over the
last six games you know they've
struggled to really move the ball on
them they've turned the ball over too
much and you know they opened up the
season last year and Tennessee one
I don't know how Tennessee Beach when's
the game I can but something tells me
it'll be closer than a seven-point line
that they have yeah but I agree I think
Jacksonville is a good team I think that
that defense the Patriots play last week
was perfect for Blake there was a lot of
windows to throw the ball in right I
think it's going to get tougher when
they play against better corners and
they play against somebody who's going
to take coal out of the game and force
the ball for Dannette not playing nobody
seems to understand for net not playing
was the best thing that happened to
Jacksonville last week because it forced
them to throw forced him to throw right
and they put loose loose backs on the
field yelled in
grant how to play and that is the
kryptonite to the Patriots defense loose
play running backs guys that can move
and a quarterback that can run around ya
know gridiron genius a master class of
winning championships and building
dynasties the NFL Lombardi or the man
don't forget leave the gun take the
cannolis thanks guys see you man be good
awesome though you've known him for a
while I've known him for a while I love
talking ball with him because he does
have so much history knowledge the
metaphors he can make things so simple
with the metaphors it's a shame he's not
in football he's not in football for one
reason cuz he keeps it real and the
NFL's political and he tells owners and
other GM's when you're stupid you're you
don't know what you're doing I'm sure
Haslam dance they a lot of them don't
like it talks to Bill I don't know I
don't know how much they talk because
like here's my here's my enjoy be very
careful with your Brady Belichick I went
for I know because he's gonna be careful
with that because he's not gonna start
news that way and he doesn't want to
make it Brady verse Belichick and all
that but at the same time how many
people in the world does Belichick call
and even give a crap what they have no
right I know like the list is probably
on one hand I would think so and three
of them probably last name is Belichick
you know right so I know that there's a
lot of fans that want to come at
Lombardi for his Doug Peterson take and
I'll be the first one to say I agreed
with Lombardi's Peterson take right when
he made that take I thought Doug
Peterson was a bad coach too old take
exposed
retweeted my tweet Doug Peterson's not a
good coach though Peterson's not a good
coach we were all shocked by that yeah
and and I think that there are a few
people in this world of football media
that I'll always listen to what they
have to say he's one of the few I am you
should because you're always look at
that he studied the thing I love to is
he really gets into the analytics where
I might just sit there I'm gonna watch
the game he's gonna go like he said you
know the 70% run and 30% pass or the
other percent you know whatever he he
just he had something else where he was
talking about how the Eagles had like a
hundred snaps last
where they were playing from behind yeah
and already this year they're at like 78
right and it's you know it's it's little
things like that but when Bill Belichick
gives you assignments to do yeah you're
going to learn a lot yes a few other
news before we jump into your notes and
then we hit up big film [ __ ] um Carson
Wentz I told you about this earlier Tim
McManus the ESPN did an article about
him and this mental coach named Ben
Newman that it's also the mental coach
for the Dolphins and with Nick Saban and
Alabama yeah and he said that Carson
Wentz is a lot like Nick Saban and what
he's found in elite performers like
wence and Sabin their level of focus and
attention to detail is so extreme it's
probably hard for the average person to
even understand
he said that whence does everything with
such a purpose that quote it makes me
more intentional in the way that I walk
it makes me a better coach it makes me a
better human being he's that intentional
of a person right Carson Wentz yeah
starting this Sunday against the goads
baby they need them and they're gonna
need them this week cuz that Colts
defense is better than I think we all
gave it credit for we're gonna get to
those a little bit and but Carson
Wentz's mindset yes it's special I think
you don't listen if he got a chance to
like evaluate a Brady or an Aaron
Rodgers or some of the other
quarterbacks Drew Brees they would
probably be in that same category where
he's like it's off the charts the the
ability to detail and like Mike said you
know it's I thought that was fascinating
point with Mike but he said about it's
hard for them to develop young players
because you do have to keep up with
Brady
it makes me look at the whole Green Bay
thing right and go wow yeah here they
are trying to keep it simple right I
guess every year they're adding a new
running back or adding a new wide
receiver I thrown in a new guard a
blogger get in there at right tackle and
they got to keep it simple but then it
still upsets me because it's Aaron
Rodgers having to do less yeah because
other people aren't doing their job
exactly exactly and we meanwhile you
know that notion that here we're saying
that Bill Belichick can't you know
girafft wide receivers maybe can't see
it but he needs to find those wide
receivers that can pick up that
no [ __ ] yes it's not easy like we've
always talked about that which is
probably why you draft so many former
quarterbacks yes I I think so well it's
just overall knowledge of the football
game and be able to digest all of it it
is a lot there's nothing like that
playbook in the NFL and knowing good
it's the most deep you know detailed in
Turkey you know just little intricacies
of things that I certainly never learned
before until I got around Josh McDaniels
and Bill this is just interesting timing
we talked about Fitz magic earlier yeah
the fact that Fitzpatrick is having this
first two weeks and Winston's out three
weeks and in the week where they're
about to play on Monday Night Football
so you know ESPN's could be talking
about Fitzpatrick a lot because they
want to pub that game Jameis Winston
gets sued for $75,000 by the uber driver
accusing him of sexual assault
I mean everything in the world the
universe is putting energy out there
Fitzpatrick not Jameis right I mean the
timing could not be worse for Winston
could not be worse certainly not it's
not a good look for him hopefully he
just pays this woman her $75,000 and
gets it done with like don't I mean he's
stupid if he tries to make this some
like I'm not gonna pay you that no you
need to get rid of this situation to you
know not only just change your life
which he needs to do obviously in the
actions and the way he acts off the
field but to get there just to get the
perception out there you don't want this
to go on for two or three more weeks
Fitzpatrick plays bad and they're still
dueling this out over the media about
him not paying the you know paying the
the whatever the hell you call that she
the accuser yes oh speaking of Monday
Night Football be doing you noticed
something on Monday Night Football I'm
gonna talk about or talk about it so
Sims has always kind of looked at the
words of coaches coach speak and I'm not
talking about coaches that go out there
and say we're on to Cincinnati and and
kind of do generalities right sometimes
coaches say things and how they say
things we were watching the game and you
noticed a graphic of try Biscay and in
the bottom corner of the screen it was a
quote from Nagy that says I'm unable to
do all of the plays in my playbook I
have to pull back what I am as a pie
caller
we're listening to the broad can the
game starts and we're listening and
we're hearing Booker MacFarlane talking
about Mitchell Trebek ease lack of four
right because Booker MacFarlane breaks
down quarterback expert know when you
listen to announcers oftentimes what
they're doing is regurgitating notes
they got in meetings with the coach s
Jason Witten they started the broadcast
and what's tessitura right
all the notes were about is try Biscay
the guy right and Sims texted me and
goes Nagy's putting this out there yes
Negi is putting this out there you know
I do things in Chicago going on the
radio going on TV there too there's
these questions that I always found it
very odd okay I found some of the
comments through the preseason odd a
little bit here and there and then yes I
mean a court may be that last preseason
game as much they play Jason Hill on to
show that he was in offense of genius oh
yeah I connect dots then I hear about
the backlash after the Green Bay game
not a real staunch defense hurmat Nagy /
true Biscay whoo yeah okay there was
maybe one or two plays where true Biscay
he'd like to have back and maybe him
pull the trigger either way but my big
thing too is let's pump the brakes on
just the overall hatred on true Biscay
first of all it's his second year in the
NFL he didn't have [ __ ] around him last
year let's just remember that Tariq Kohn
was his best receiver Tariq own their
backup running back was the best
receiver on the football team
hands down when they were like man we
needs if somebody to run a post corner
on third and 17 they put their back up
running back at receiver and now he's in
his second game of a new offense second
game of a new offense so I'm listening
to the telecast and like you said when
things like that come out as the theme
like sim to me if I was gonna broadcast
the game you could only take to what a
coach says to a degree the coach is
gonna push his own propaganda oh you
mean when Monday Night Football and
booger McFarlane went on during the
preseason and said that Alex Smith is a
better quarterback than Keys right so
here's the note for everybody listening
to Monday Night Football right when
booger McFarlane says something it's
right out of the words of the coach's
mouth because he's taking it and then
just putting it on the air right so so
realize that it's propaganda right and
and I always found it my way to go okay
hey I'm gonna take some of what he said
yeah
evaluations and I know football too and
just cuz you know hey this is do you
want to hear a real quick one real quick
the propaganda denver broncos von
Miller's contract year Wade Phillips and
company we're trying to tell everybody
that DeMarcos DeMarcus Ware was the best
pass rusher on their team you were
broadcasting in broadcast
no is a year we've with Carolina and
Denver played attachable the reason he
was saying that because they were trying
to keep bond Miller for the low they
didn't want to have to pay him ninety
million so if the announcers keep saying
DeMarcus Ware is really the key to this
defends their incepting the fan exactly
you know where's just as good as actly
right so you have to be careful about
the [ __ ] you listen to so we get to
the telecast of the game and it says
Mitchell chubowski second overall pick
14th NFL start seven pass to D seven
interceptions quote on the bottom Matt
Nagy I have to pull back what I am as a
play caller what a cheap shot chicken
[ __ ] move okay I don't know what else to
say about it
that is what see this is what coaches
drive me crazy with first of all that
would be like let's show a Mike McCarthy
quote card and then there's Mike
McCarthy's picture his career record and
one Super Bowl run and then there's a
quote on the bottom from Aaron Rodgers
says I've been carrying this
[ __ ] for 10 years that's what it
I mean that's basically what he did to
Mitchell job risky here's the thing
right in the same draft right the Bears
didn't take to Shaun Watson or Patrick
Mahone
yeah who Matt Negi just coached right do
you believe that [ __ ] sitting there
going I just got to see Patrick mahomes
in practice for a year and now I'm here
with try Biscay do you think he's
sitting there with sour grapes well I
think there's a little bit of he knows
how special my Holmes is and you know
again okay but you took the Bears job
and this is your quarterback and this is
what bothers me about it is again you
know coaches will tell players that keep
things in the locker room yes and keep
things in to me don't blame just
evaluate yourself but they're the first
people to blame always the coaches are
the ones that leave out the meeting room
and they call Adam Schefter and call
Chris Mortensen and you know call all of
those guys to let you know all
this information but they just got done
telling their team what we says what's
said in here stays in here and it's just
bother some [ __ ] coaching talk
hypocritical yes
like like Gruden's saying it's really
hard to find a great pass rusher like
it's just you know no it's not there's
good ones out there yeah just do
penitence I'm the best player on your
team and you're coming up with it that
would be Gruden being like Khalil Mack
didn't want to be here but yeah exactly
right but so my point is there that that
bothers me and that tells me okay they
might not be happy and thrilled with
Mitchell job risky yeah and yeah he
maybe he doesn't understand the full
scope of their offense and I've heard
little things about yeah Mitchell true
Biscay is not like the sharpest
quarterback in football okay but there's
been Dumber to have success and this is
that you took this job in Chicago you
knew what you're getting I would argue
that Mitchell true Brisky has more
talent than Alex Smith and you can still
make it work without undermining his
credibility with the football team or
just making up excuses already to say oh
my offense I'm not being able to show
the whole repertoire because of my
quarterback I just I think that's a BS
well it's better job security in Chicago
the third pick in the draft to the new
coach the new coach probably right now
yeah he's kind of got them by the balls
as for now right it'll be interesting to
watch how that plays out have you ever
heard of a coaching quarterback like a
high would like not liking each other uh
I can't think of anything right off the
top of my head but alright well let's
talk about our favorite quarterback yeah
let's do some game notes got 20 minutes
till Phil Simms comes on so we're gonna
start off with Packers offense taking on
the Vikings defense
you said Rodgers is moving as well as
you can write so far nothing looks
different about the Green Bay offense
the only difference is they have more
double moves to keep the defense off it
honest this year that's the only thing
I've seen in two weeks
you know so this revamping of the
offensive playbook and Green Bay which
is not possible I would argue again
Green Bay's coaches on the offensive
side of the ball don't know what they
don't even know that's what I would say
to run plays they have to run plays
inside zone and outside zone whoa man
get ready defenses but yes they're doing
that just
the double moves in the passing game so
that they could keep us laugh and still
do their same old BS that's an
improvement it is an improvement at
least it's aggressive which I like
little Cowboys Romo s yeah sure exactly
right you know I don't always have to
reinvent the wheel just I provide
different look it is provide different
look keep keep a guy like Xavier Rhodes
from jumping under routes and slant and
routes and yeah it'll make him think
twice with a guy like Aaron Rodgers and
you wrote men the Packers running backs
are so average I've never seen a team so
bad at evaluating such an easy position
you did say Montgomery's better than
William I do I think Montgomery this is
a more explosive player like when
there's something there to be had he can
maximize to play more and yeah it's
going back to like will Lombardi said
you know you know receivers can't New
England's not good at evaluating his
receivers but damn every year Pittsburgh
picks one on the draft and he's a star
right they have the eye for it and in
Green Bay they do not have the eye for
the running back position for the last
eight to nine years it's just I mean
come on we're seeing special guys in the
NFL right now like Phillip Lindsey and
the Denver Broncos who wasn't even
drafted they're growing on trees in a
lot of places yeah
anything else I'm gonna switch over to
Vikings offense was there anything else
you definitely wanted to talk to about
the Packers offense and the Vikings
defense I mean they're like the biggest
thing I think is at the end of the game
the Green Bay Packers settle for three
field lows those first two field goal
drives they tried to be where Johnny
gonna run the ball and run out the clock
and you know what happened nothing
happened and I've heard people get on
McCarthy for maybe not great clock
management on the last one cuz he threw
the ball three straight times with
Rodgers well he learned his lesson from
the first two I what I'm saying is I'm
not gonna be mad at him for the throwing
the ball at the end with the ball which
he should have done the two drives
before that couch and then Rodgers made
two unbelievable throws remember the
Davante Adams one yes he drops going
down into the end zone gosh and then the
very next play there was a back shoulder
to Davante Adams and he drops it in the
corner of the end zone so he delivered
and Devante usually makes those catches
but that's all I would say about that
Vikings offense Packers defense two
notes on the Packers here that I wrote
down Packers are using Josh Jackson
correctly yeah the third safety right
and they're typically having along some
Rudolph a little exactly right sometimes
he's in the box almost as like a
linebacker other times he's that third
safety covering tight ends he's a
liability on the outside he's not gonna
be able to cover and change directions
with the digs of the world but you get
him inside on Kyle Rudolph for those
bigger type of guys he's very good and
he has a great understanding of football
in general he's a player he really
understands what the defense is trying
to accomplish what the offense is trying
to accomplish and that's why you saw him
get a picks in college it wasn't cuz he
was this great man-to-man corner he's
watching he's a great deal and then when
the ball came his way he gets his hands
on he catches it you said the big
question for the Packers defense moving
forward is Devon House yes and you said
that he was replaced by JR Alexander
late yeah and he stepped up he did I
mean Jair is pretty special I do think
that but yes I mean so you like you're
ready to commit
Josh accident a year to good picks yes
to get picks I am ready to say that jr.
is a great checkers move down and take
those two guys from the Colton Miller
trade with the Raiders right and they
got a first-round pick next year I know
so they they hit out there that was that
was phenomenal you know Kevin King
that's why I was saying if Kevin Kings
hurt which I don't know his status will
be this week yeah then that means the
Devon house has to get into this
conversation and that scares me I don't
think they can trust the Vaughn house on
the outside anymore I think his day of
having that extra gear to keep up with
some of those elite receivers like we
saw Diggs who just blew by him and
that's when he came out of the game they
did he did get back in a little bit in
overtime and stuff but yeah that's the
stuff that would scare me I could tell
though you really like pettings defense
right now I really do like Patton's
defense you know there was a hair a few
plays here and there that maybe they
were a hair over aggressive back-to-back
weeks that you're coming away impressed
yeah he's he understands the other
offense he comes up with creative
coverages where you just go I don't
really know what this coverage is but
he's got everybody dropped in the right
spot that's a little bit like what you
used to say about dusky exactly right
and I think with that and then you know
those big three in the middle of yeah
there's a lot to like about this defense
did of the Vikings OCD Phillip oh did he
impress you anymore this week no and I
think that's the other point with Penton
too like they both know Cleveland
together well people yeah and they write
and they're people are gonna look at
Patton and go well I mean they
up a lot of big place yes they did but
they were insane throws bike her cousin
exactly right left go like I would I
would challenge Kirk to make those
throws every week I mean it he's threw
the ball as good as he's ever thrown
yeah
and you know listen the one thing I love
about Kirk is he drops back and he sees
it he lets it go it ain't no like oh I'm
gonna second-guess in the hat the ball
here I saw it correctly and I'm gonna
fire it and but hey Alex Smith can run
though Yeah right yeah good luck that
should end this weekend thank you for
bringing that up match this weekend
should've ended that conversation
everybody in Washington DC if you think
Alex nothing's better than Kirk Cousins
you're just wrong and you got a deal
with that but yeah I mean Cousins was
amazing cousins got overshadowed by the
mahomes it's Patrick story this weekend
he went into Green Bay and scored 22
points in the fourth quarter against
Aaron Rodgers and the Green Bay Packers
and it wasn't like he threw three yard
slants and people ran for 70 the Davis
touchdown was great the feel and touch
was insane still don't understand how it
got through oh I really think Jair
Alexander is going to intercept the pass
or at least break it up but he paused
because he was afraid I think it was
Kentrell Bryce was gonna knock him out
okay literally cross a home and they
almost did kill each other but that was
unbelievable his Kurt was also getting
hit as he was throwing that ball and he
threw a 30-yard rope and it was pretty
impressive it's a tie
but how do you feel afterwards about
both of those teams I am still more
positive I still have questions about
Minnesota I'm still the defensive line
does question I question Tom Johnson I
know that's gonna be nice and the o-line
same feeling so I you know again I know
Minnesota's good I'm just not ready to
do like last year I felt like I was
ready at this point to kind of anoint
them like now they're on another level I
don't know why this year here a line and
the depth of the D line is still scary
it does scare me Green Bay when Aaron
Rodgers gets healthy if Aaron Rodgers
had a regular leg in that game yeah you
said though they're gonna win the game
yeah well but Texans are going to that
my Super Bowl picks like really shitty
yeah they're both oh whoa one in one
yeah you're right
no yeah you're right now yes yeah they
are Bucks offense Eagles no the Saints
won oh yeah they want yeah they should
have any time
Cleveland could screw up a wet dream is
what you're telling me the Browns can
screw up a wet dream it's about to be
climax and I go what I'm awake I'm awake
Buck's offense Eagles defense you put it
plainly this is the best that
Fitzpatrick has ever thrown it your big
question though the Eagles defense was
why are they playing so many guys to the
line of scrimmage you wrote this
multiple times of your notes why do the
Eagles have eight guys to line of
scrimmage there are five people on earth
who can cover Mike Evans and DeSean
Jackson and the Eagles don't have any of
the five they like that alive yes yes
you said that if you're gonna play Tampa
Bay and we'll see if Pittsburgh does
this on Monday night you have to call
their bluff and see if they're gonna run
it they don't want to run it wwbd
what would bella check do right I mean I
guarantee of Belichick gonna play the
Buccaneers you go they don't want to run
the ball I'm gonna put my bear fun put
three big people in front of their
garden centers and I'm gonna drop seven
and eight the whole game and I'm gonna
make them run it and show me they're
gonna continually stay with it and gash
me with that like no one's talking like
no one talks about the Tampa Bay running
backs at all right now no they can't do
crap I'm like yeah but yet we're loading
the box that's I think can you
understand why the Eagles did that it I
don't because I was actually very
impressed with a lot of shorts is
playing more zone and being better that
way this year but in some key moments of
the football game he went back to Jimmy
meathead Schwartz where it was like I'm
gonna crown in scrimmage and you're not
gonna run for one foot on me great
it makes him run don't let em Evans and
DeSean Jackson at the end of the game I
mean they were literally fitzpatrick out
of the line of scrimmage was like oh
great they have nine guys at the line of
scrimmage DeSean and Mike Evans are
one-on-one I can close my eyes lob it
high and they'll make up they're gonna
remember they're gonna run 15-yard
comebacks and jaylen meals and Ronald
Darby cam is so scared they're running
go rounds they're gonna be wide open and
the game will be over and that's what
happened that the game would have been
over on before Evans fumbled right that
was the same time a defensive look it
was 27 to 14 they're gonna we're gonna
crowd the line of scrimmage yeah and
they threw a comeback to Mike Evans he
ended up fumble
because Mike Jenkins punched it out
which was awesome yes but that was the
same thing there Malcolm Jenkins sorry
yeah nobody to me it's like when I hear
Todd Bowles the other day go we really
need to establish the run unlike guys
stop focusing on this establishing the
run
we live in a world now where the NFL you
should pass on early downs and spread it
out and then run when it's threatened
world right it's just like this I'm
tougher than you machismo guttural 1990s
thoughts still stop being an old right
exactly right be like Bill Belichick and
move on with the times the 275 yard
touchdowns you said one Eagles call it a
corner blitz and they just got bad
coverage for Malcolm Jenkins their main
site a game right yes um yeah and then
on the OJ Howard touchdown they had an
inverted cover to right for everyone out
there cover two typically is the corner
sits down the flat yeah and the safety
goes over on that side of the field
right invert it is you play your safety
at the corner spot and your corner at
the safety spot because you want your
better tackler in the flat so they
wanted Malcolm Jenkins in the flat right
but guess what happened Oh J Howard went
up the seam Darby was there and Darby
looked at OJ Howard and went Oh career
decision and missed the tackle and then
Howard was off to exactly right so it
was just they had an idea but OJ Howard
got loose and Darby made a bet right
exactly right that's why you know
sometimes you will say defensive coaches
are just gonna know I'm gonna play my
guys where they're supposed to play
because of little things like that I
understand they're trying to pay a pass
defense and he was trying to cheat and
put Malcolm Jenkins up there at the line
of scrimmage in case they ran a strong
side run over there whatever it may be
right but Howard is a freak show and
Fitzpatrick made a great throw right on
the backside of Hicks's head yes and
then Darby had a tackle and that's not
why he's getting big checks it's not
Virginia's for an Eagles team that
allowed two touchdowns on 75 yards and
then to allow like 313 points the rest
of the game I think maybe the reason
they loaded the box don't run the ball
on us don't waste the time we need the
time for our offense let's go the other
side of the ball yeah Eagles offense
bucks D you think that D line is stout
it's gonna be hard to run on them I do
think so I mean when you just break down
big yeah Vinnie Curry
pierre-paul and Gerald McCoy and they
don't even have feet of a about I know
and and and just those four alone though
like jpp and Vinny Curie are some of the
best run stopping defense ends in
football cuz they're quick and they're
strong they're strong as hell to 80 ish
type of guys the long arm so they can
set the edge or they can just power
tackles back yes so it like like the New
Orleans Saints I would be shocked
they're not gonna continue no have
running marathons on the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers like they did last year or
the Carolina Panthers for them yeah it's
good for them because I was annoyed
watching the Bucs last season Eagles
offense you wrote they have no wide
receivers Wallace went out they got to
stay patient with the edge run and
whence will help their running game yes
he will because even though I want we
want ones to be careful but whence even
with a half a leg is faster than Nick
Foles
so did the read option the bootlegs all
those things are going to scare teams
even though they know that's not gonna
be the same Carson Wentz they're gonna
see enough to know damn we got to be
honest on the backside and your bread
and butter and some of the things you
guys do up front you have some very
athletic offensive linemen I mean Lane
Johnson Kelsey's maybe them one of the
most athletic centers in football is it
to the point where whence can get out
further for the edge run then foals can
and so you're actually giving the ball
to Cory Clement a little bit further out
in the analyzing it to be mad
that's certainly and then also just
think about shotgun right you're in the
shotgun you're back to the right and
let's say we want to run left well when
they do that little action and hold it
the linebacker might pause a second with
Carson once he might go he just went and
I don't think you guys were patient
enough with those type of runs you kind
of gashed him every time you ran those
type of runs you know there was moments
where you tried to run it up the middle
and I want a big net it's just not not
against this group this year you're not
gonna do that against Tampa interesting
so stay with what works and then also
what else is gonna help the run game
with wins I mean people are gonna be
scared once can throw the [ __ ] ball
wherever he wants and whenever he was
just not been know so once is a special
thrower and he can beat you all
different types of throws to where
defenses are gonna air a little more on
coverage now than going down hills on
this current team both fall as a
quarterback they do have injuries a
corner for Tampa Bay yeah
Rimes was out Vernon Hargreaves former
top-10 pick out for the year you loved a
guy in the draft and your parent lis
loving him now Carlton Davis from Auburn
you wrote my man Carlton Davis looks
really good got a chance to be very good
dude
late third quarter Carlton Davis is
owning people at the line of scrimmage I
remember the draft you talked about how
long is reaches right you wrote they put
Davis on hurts and got hurt a few times
just talk about Carlton Davis and maybe
what they found in Tim yeah I mean he's
he's just the guy that jumped out at me
first of all he's SEC corner that was
left on an island a lot okay so when
you're doing that the SEC is so much
better than the rest of college football
it's not funny there's a reason they've
won ten out of the last twelve BCS
Championships okay thank you
and yeah I hate when people say it's not
the case no I mean it's ridiculous
exactly right and maybe a Clemson it's
the SEC verse then so but I am a fan of
Michigan I know sorry you're not on
their level Michigan or anybody in the
pac-12 or my Texas who sucks so don't
lie God yeah I like Texas so I'd like to
root for them but we suck and we're not
on that level but he's six one two oh
three
he's got incredibly long arms and four
long guys like that his change of
direction skills are what's really
impressive and yes he got a few of your
receivers at the line of scrimmage a few
times
whether it was Tregs or Ament even Elson
Aguilar where they couldn't get three
yards down the field I mean he put his
arms out he locked them up and I do
think one of his hidden values will be
the fact of like you know you heard
Jalen Ramsey about covering Gronk and
all that he can be that kind of guy you
know they put him on Dallas Gadar in the
end zone one time and they tried to run
a quarter route to Dallas garnered damn
Dallas Carter couldn't get into the end
zone
because he was just all over those guys
are so valued right they call the pass
interference on Carlton Davis one time
if you remember I know you were watching
the game closely but early through like
a curl route to the right two earths and
hey there was some contact going on
Earth's was hitting him at all but I
mean it was just he was all over him
like a glove and I just thought it was
encouraging I think they got somebody
special down MJ Stewart might have to go
to safety I think so I mean at Nikol
Josh Jackson exactly right it just it's
uh it's it's a little compromised I
can't remember
the exact play they were in a shallow
cross and it might have been Nelson
Aguilar he just went off and it was him
covering Amanda man he couldn't even
stay with him no it was it was like
you're watching Nelson Aguilar and MJ
Stewart looked like he was in SLO
exactly when you get done that watching
that game yeah and now they're facing
Pittsburgh right this is gonna be a
desperate Pittsburgh team and this is a
Tampa Bay that Mike Tomlin said this
press conference their big play offense
yeah I don't really see Pittsburgh from
what you're telling me pushing this
defensive line around but they I mean
they should be able to throw on Tampa
yes they should
Pittsburgh should be able to do that the
question is will Tampa be able to throw
on Pittsburgh that would be the question
and yeah I don't know I'm hoping I will
be you know we're going to look at it
and go just what we just talked about
they're gonna call their bluff they're
gonna go we got cam Hayward because we
you you kept saying in the Kansas City
game that Pittsburgh would drop back in
a zone and that the Kansas City could
tear it up yeah I to me sitting back in
his own against Fitzpatrick is what you
do yeah I think so - he's not Patrick
mahomes he's not gonna throw lasers
through his own thumb because often
times people he does and if you give him
time certainly he's gonna carve you up
and they have some weapons but yeah I
would think Pittsburgh would play this
smart and go run the ball if you want we
want to see you do it and we'll drop
eight and people into the coverages and
into Windows and hopefully we can just
get in Fitzpatrick's face from time to
time the big thing with with um you know
Pittsburgh is there's just no Joe Hayden
which one is he gonna be back because
that you know they're just there they
just need smarter guys in the field they
do there are liability if they have to
play man-to-man they just don't have
enough guys that can play pure cover one
Tim desperate Pittsburgh desperate
Pittsburgh Monday night Tony Dungy going
to the ring of fame and they're gonna
deal with it oh it's in Tampa in Tampa
nice hot nice hot night humidity at 90%
speaking of a hot night let's get big
fill up a big [ __ ] talk a little
dolphins jets with him do you think he'd
enjoy that oh yeah he definitely would
and I think there was a few other things
he was actually yeah what do you got on
his mind let's see he was uh you know
maybe Andy Reed LA Rams Josh Rosen
Dallas some
cool stuff to talk about on defense so
we'll see where he wants to go with it
yeah oh well hey you don't know what to
say cuz we called you a minute early huh
no you know I have no idea what time it
was I'm you know trying to do some work
here to get my son some information to
help him out every once awhile you know
I mean is that the key to this that's
the secret you damn right
hey listen Adam yeah I had to get on the
phone with him last night and explain to
him because him and his Mike Florio on
their radio commentary in the morning
they're talking about pelts on the wall
okay you know I know what it was like
what the hell is a Pelt it's like it's
like the skin of an animal right yeah I
didn't know that it's not that's not
what you talked about you know it comes
from this as Parcells is the one that
started this hey don't tell me you're a
good fur trapper when I go out and see
your horse and I don't see any pelts on
that horse mmm horse I have a lot of
pelts on it right so when bill people
would say that bill
oh so it's those great hey hey you got
any pelts I went outside look there's no
pelts in a horse don't tell me about
that right and that's where it comes
from
of course they're going Oh pelts from
the wall gotta have a lot of wall what
are you doing you go kill the animal and
you put his Pelt on the wall so what it
was I guess I didn't know what the hell
I mean you know I said I didn't know
what the pelts were I just did it was
actually boreal they're talking about
pelts on the wall so he's an idiot too
okay good both of you just say that's a
partnership is about throw the other one
underwear anytime you can go under fill
we saw the opposite of that from the
Jets receivers we heard at noon wha and
who's the guy that came over from
Washington terrelle pryor Pryor both
come out and say listen those plays they
were my fault they were not Sam
Darnell's fault
Sims came away so impressed with Sam
Donaldson a Christian since are
wondering Chris came away so impressed
with Sam Donald's film that he said left
Co let me get his phone number I want to
text them and I hear you were impressed
with Sam Darnell too even though I got
Jets fans in the office
being like I don't know about saying I'm
going trust me Oh
send him straight Phil set him straight
get those jet bands on the phone put the
loudspeaker up god I mean come on
first tall piece of rookie he's making
his second start and all we're gonna
just look at the negative so that's it
and terrelle pryor is right any time
you're running the inside route what's
the golden rule in football don't run a
bit vendor cross your face he got pulled
they should have called pass
interference I'm just trying to say I'm
not trying to just saying I know
Turo priors the kind of guy that's not
gonna make excuses he doesn't know you
he doesn't complain to the refs I've
just I watched the film last night you
know that he was role should've NPI
should have been oh why I actually
watched it I did not see it ya know that
go back and look you're a little old
your eyes you know sorry
well that's true I'm sitting here doing
it I'm telling you I had to go I just
got done washing my face and this times
like damn I can't keep my eyes open keep
going about Donald um but I listen to
things first off is he's a better pro
quarterback right now than I saw in
college much more discipline doing
things I never saw him do in college
setting his feet you know I don't to get
all technical okay but we talking about
I did his 30s he's actually going oh
this guy's not open he's not open
hang in there feel the pressure and then
make the throw to the third guy very
uncommon for almost all quarterbacks in
the NFL and extremely uncommon for a
rookie you know I love it on TV the old
Evelyn says poor choice now goes shut up
that was not you know Christopher you
played how many times you get oh I went
to London all the way across the field
and found my fourth guy yeah right who
were you playing Yeah right
you're your bad pass reason right
so when I hear that on TV it's very very
rare I was going to say when I hear that
on TV it's nonsense oh it's not Ben I
need to do a column just on nonsense
that said you know everybody now dude
Patrick mahomes is gonna be really good
I knew he was gonna be a star
shut up again I didn't hear his name
draft night I didn't hear him by saying
they need to move up to get him
but they'll now now they knew okay the
only person I truly know and I talked to
a lot of people during the draft says
they're always calling me and I got
started late on that draft is that
knucklehead sitting next to you at him
yeah I'm having breakfast one morning he
calls me and he says hey dad have you
watched passion around homes yet
I said boss I'm on TV I know he's good
okay I'll watch him but you know
Christopher the season just kind of
ended and I need a little break I can't
start watching you know draft stuff he
goes when you see my homes I'm telling
you he's great he's great
I've never seen he's great and went on
and I hung up the phone I said oh hell
now I'm at the go upstairs and put it up
and start watching Lilith and you know
it was it was he looked in college I
don't know if he looked as good in
college as he did it he has so far to
two games as a pro right because their
offense is a little managers go I mean
you might his man's weekend Texas Tech's
backup quarterback threw for five
hundred and sixty yards or something all
right right yeah well whatever
what do you think about Amy Reed's
offense and Patrick mahomes well going
the last thing no let me finish out for
the jet fans what do you expect and and
and and I just thought he did more in
that game as a quarterback than I saw in
his time I know it was short at USC as
far as playing the position the right
way and he threw the ball with power
down the field he did which I have not
seen yet so that would that was
impressive I agree I think there's two
things like they just technically like
you said the foot thing
shoulder turn certainly they're more
than I remember in two hands on the
football I think has changed his game
yeah he was a white guy right when and
then sometimes when you one-handed like
you always hear me say your arm acts
like the independent contractor and I
was exactly right and I was always like
damn I mean the ball is all over the
place on your two hands and you're kind
of riding there you have to get your
body involved right and that's a really
simple thing it's the first thing I
teach everybody y'all watch them and
they always have their hands separated
stop I yell at the keys poor little kids
they go what two hands on the ball and
they drop it I can see that front of
hand get stopped I make him stop get out
of there and she's a center
again and I just keep you know do they
Poli then they'll put two hands on and
throw it I said yeah what and they go
you were right mr. Simms oh thank you
okay I'll make him thank me you know so
it's good it's good being on a power
trip wait Andy Reid go ahead okay yeah
well what do we need to know now okay
Andy Reid's had got a little belly check
in him he could just keep marching along
I mean I don't think he gets tired of
the process he just kind of he just
keeps going along doing his thing and I
it's really impressive he's done a lot
of different things in his career with
quarterbacks but what he's done with my
homes and what they do on offense is
nothing that we've ever seen from him
and it is truly now I know it has a lot
to do a couple things really good
offensive line yeah a mobile quarterback
a terrific arm and throwing to and you
know I hate all these say you know he
might be the best receiver in football I
mean he's on that discussion well I
don't but just the whole group yeah
running back you know you put it all
together and then oh my gosh we get to
accentuate it with a great arm so it's
everything it's it's the players to
skill the receivers that the offensive
line a quarterback with a great arm and
then a coach with the imagination and
the guts to say we're gonna let this
thing go and I crystal I know you've
already told Adam I mean he could have
thrown eight touchdowns in that game
right and it was some good stuff new
stuff but it's just the speed and the
arm strength are the two main things
that are making it happen right really
could really climb I'm just telling you
I'm just like going I didn't know Andy
Reid had this in him because I haven't
seen it and so so long he's awesome you
watch that and you see the throws and
then I go watch some other games and I
just go man it is truly keep the ball I
think the Miami Dolphins in Week one
only threw three passes I think I've
told you over 10 yards in the air yeah
they're making Tannehill a real game
manager that's what they did when he was
healthy two years ago well you know I
think that's Adam GaSe he's trying to
a little bit of everything control the
game protect this offensive line which
is it's pretty good and he's learning
and you know as time goes on they will
open it up more and more but there and
and and also you know like I said hold
the ball the way they do it just keeps
her defense on the side hey Phil you
know what impressed with Miami being to
it all of course fills you know what
Miami's record is the last ten games
that Ryan Tannehill started liars ten I
think I mean not in one I thought I
thought it was like eleven of twelve I
think yeah I think it eleven in one I
love the same process yeah it is that's
pretty good that tells you something but
you know it's it's it's a kind of a hard
way to play in the league nowadays -
yeah but calm down last people what well
you know it's it's too many good
defenders in other words man now the
pressure is sometimes you got to
complete three passes get the first down
and you know so what happens when you
get a penalty you get a negative you run
the ball loose four yards all of a
sudden you're like oh now we got to try
to do something that we're really not
doing a lot so that'll be interesting to
see how that goes along but you got to
give them credit so far they look like a
different team yeah I mean they let some
really good players get away from their
franchise yes they did and there is a
toughness to them when you watch them
play I really thought I saw that against
the Jets right I thought that Jets in
Miami game was a really good watch just
to see two teams really going after it
and some key players just making big
plays really really you know really kind
of well done but both teams I feel you
like to bust our balls and I'll tell you
what man people were coming after me as
an Eagles fan because Simms knock Chris
and I both picked Dallas to win the NFC
East and I'm curious I hear that you
have some interesting notions about
their defense you'd like to talk about
make me feel better about my pick your
blissing we know they got a really good
defensive front actually their defensive
front even better than I thought it was
gonna be you know I just forgot I said
man they still got David Irving coming
back and I gotta get healthy Randy
Gregory Randy Gregory is he in
concussion protocol yeah I think he's
gonna be back this will be back this
right
oh I mean listen there that and I know
the Giants made mistakes and this go on
and on you know I I don't care it was
still it was an avalanche and Rod
Marinelli just we know Christopher knows
you've heard all that but Chris Rashard
has come over from the Seattle Seahawks
I always thought I really thought he'd
have been a head coach by now and I've
many many times and we talk and you just
go you know and I think you guys know
this when you talk to certain guys you
go god he's got it right right you know
he's meant to be a leader of men and I
know he's a good football coach I
thought he was pretty creative out in
Seattle but when you watch Dallas play
the Giants the Giants just didn't come
out and run you know little simple
things they were trying a lot of ways to
get big plays to fold the defense to
break down the rules of what the defense
is supposed to do and I'm telling you
the Cowboys didn't break until that last
touchdown throw that Eli Manning had
which I still don't know I forgot to
safety that came up what hell he was
doing but they were great they they did
concepts to try to fool the corner Byron
Jones they tried to get him he didn't
fall for it so took away a big play the
safeties did great I mean they passed
everything off which is you know when
you're passing like let the receiver
goal but somebody else might be coming
you know the these key bits of players
they always alarm will stay with him and
get it make it happen right
it looks like the defensive linemen you
all play the running coach it really all
he cares about a sack and a quarterback
and kind of the same buddy with
defensive backs but really disciplined
and extremely impressed in the first two
games what they've done with the
secondary so I have some non football
things that I'd like to ask you are you
okay with that Ebert color is blue is it
really alright so so in the Sims and
left go Instagram DMS which I'm sure as
a sentence that you're gonna have to
take a few hours to understand yeah Josh
vendrick was talking with a fan and he
and the fan said I love the podcast let
me see if I can find the guy's name it
is Jay Bronstein so shout out to Jay
love the podcast I went on a bachelor
party this week and I was talking about
the podcast when it
kid from Franco Lakes told me a story
about how Dierdre used to throw bangers
which means big parties yet a Sims house
in high school said that big Phil used
to be there and he would call them all
big idiots and if they were too drunk he
would call their parents to pick them up
true or false true so you walk around
the party like hey your big idiots I'm
calling you now listen it happened I
think probably with all my kids yes
you know I know what happened my son
Matt they had a football game I was home
I got to go to the game because it was
the week before the NFL season started
and I don't know what I was doing on his
upstairs I know what the hell's going on
I walked out in my basement and it's
packed and one of his buddies I walk
walk into the room and he goes old mr.
Sims hi I said put that out you you know
whatever I said something very vulgar
till he because he was smoking and not a
cigarette oh you jerk and I look at Matt
well what did he goes oh yeah I forgot
to tell you I was gonna have a few guys
over to the game oh okay yeah you forgot
to tell me and oh man this is this one a
kid left Deirdre's party one night yes
got into my car right and drove home he
lived like tell him where he lives like
five houses down the street no no two
ounces from where we live - yes - up the
street yeah he gets in the car and
what's he do Christopher he runs over he
he ran into a tree didn't need some
pylons or whatever that stuff really
just destroys my car right because it
did look a little bit like his and I
always keep my keys in my car I don't
take them out that's very Kentucky of
you yes it is well I just you know
that's why I never lose my keys you know
they're always in my car so it makes it
simple yeah oh yeah but he comes he
tells me you know I find out whatever I
go I'm just mad as hell and he's such a
good kid
please mr. Sims don't tell my mom and
dad I get it fixed I'll pay every penny
or whatever for and he did well I got it
fixed and he paid me all the money and I
let him skate not
awesome this guy J also deemed he says
Phil even called out another of my
friends at pari sees saying that he
wasn't lifting enough weight are you the
guy he definitely is about was probably
just busting somebody you know what are
you doing over there man you turning
like here you know what are you trying
to do here you know whatever I do that
all the time kids well the best is dad
like that won't let people sometimes
like you know there's that big muscle
meathead in the gym who you know can
like benchpress 400 pounds and do all
that and they might walk off the dad and
go hey Phil what could you bench in your
day and Davin go up five fifty five
forty five and never be like because
they wanted to be able to say they beat
him of that and then dad would just walk
away straight face and they were totally
ruined though he didn't know he didn't
actually benchpress 500-pound oh yeah
but he wasn't gonna let them have that
joy to go like you can't do what I do
that's right that's right and that guy
those guys that used to come over that
is all muscle-bound in the chest
they got legs like a chicken that's
right they knows always love that too
you know I go to the gym not much down
during I work out here at home and
mostly during the season because I don't
want to take the time to drive in and
all that but when you go to the gym
there's two sides and Christopher knows
the place and one side is kind of
training for athletes and they train
people on the other sides of gym right
and on the other side the gym every guy
in there is doing curls benching and
whatever and what do you think all the
women are doing but leg lifts and stuff
I mean they're just doing squats
guys I mean it's it's it's hilarious it
is hilarious I mean it is almost a
hundred percent when I go to the gym and
see it I go I don't know when's the last
time I looked over and saw a guy do
something for his legs you know we all
kind of I up or whatever and you know so
oh well alright Kook is a crap yeah you
know yeah I thought it was fun it was
fun you know
Adam I need to take you and work you out
one day just see what you got well I'm
excited because I think for the show
we're gonna go and hang out with you
soon so I'm against what I hear you're
gonna come up rule in my day my whole
week I'm gonna you know stay up till
midnight every damn that's okay
Phil I just think I just want you to
know that I really appreciate this whole
little cat-and-mouse about you being
annoyed by us I really all look I know
I'm only around here I'm here to serve
you guys okay so that's all we'd like to
hear okay all right you know what that's
it [ __ ] so not like him to say that
with a with the microphone on TV or
anything
you see gonna let that fly yes they
better all right I'm gonna say this QC
we love you I'm gonna say this our show
our podcast we've been working on it for
a long time yeah and I think that we've
taught a lot of people a lot of things
whether it's football whether it's
scheme whether it's you know players and
the grass not turf or beans not beef but
if all the things we've done humanizing
your dad is my favorite thing that's
good because all the time that we spent
with Phil and I would go he's not like
what everyone thinks he is on TV yeah
and it's one of the things we get
message the most from people a thank you
for showing me a side of Phil Simms I
didn't know was there I'm glad everybody
gets to see it really because I you know
sure it annoyed you for it does I know
my dad and I know he just he's uh he's
mr. proper on TV at times and wasn't
that day not only it was a smart
businessman to be there yes and he's
just too he's not gonna ever take that
chance to compromise a coach or a player
or do that way but he does have a lot
more personality than people realize
it's funny this is completely unrelated
but somewhat so Will Smith did an
interview and he was talking about how
when he was coming up movie stars were
unreachable the only time you saw them
was when they had a movie premiere and
they were on the red carpet other than
that vanished that was the point that's
how you became a movie star right and
the reason he's so big on social media
right now is because he looked around
and said if you want to be a movie star
now you got to be a movie star all the
time you know the the big people are big
on social media that's more important
sometimes than the premiere or the movie
and I think a lot with your dad he was
on TV during the you'd only see me when
I'm doing Foxborough and its Patriots
Bronco
and now you know Romo is out here doing
commercials and Gruden was out there
doing commercials and everyone's on
social media and you're not just gonna
get my takes on Sunday here's me
pointing to a television on a random
Tuesday on Twitter and I'm breaking it
down it's about accessibility right and
I think that you know he kind of looked
at it as like the insta face the snap
ground yeah I guess just to finish up
dolphins Jets you came away very
impressed with the Jets defense their
front seven very versatile and you don't
think that any old line will be a
mismatch and that will include Thursday
against Cleveland no I don't I just
think they they have it all when you
really break down the roster on the
front seven right like oh okay you've
got a play a athletic offensive line
like that can get out on the outside and
outside zone and pulling guards and all
that stuff okay well they can get small
and and and get out there and play that
style of football and at the same time
they can go well we can get gigantic too
if the Dallas Cowboys rolled into town
right and we could stop you from
smashing it down in our face so I always
like that about a football team one
thing that kind of a little a few
negative things here about the Dolphins
often you definitely believe that the
Jets dominated this game just the Jets
for the better football team I will say
this to defend the Dolphins they didn't
really ever have to open up because the
Jets players messed up some plays early
on to where the Dolphins were afforded
the luxury of money you wrote the
Dolphins offensive super boring super
worried of it all no but that's not gay
psyche I don't think that's gonna
continue I don't think so either
and but maybe they were just trying to
be boring because they got an
interception which gave them the ball
210 exactly you know and they were able
to score right there up 22 not that a
nice Albert Wilson touchdown exactly
right so yeah I know it's out of the
full picture I do still think the Jets
were the better football team on the
field you did write 10 L has a fumbling
problem holy [ __ ] I mean it's just the
ball looks so big in his hands sometimes
and I don't know what his size of his
hands were coming out in the draft I
don't think it can be very big but yeah
I mean the ball is just anybody that
touches his arm or his shoulder the ball
falls out and I just worry about it I
mean and then of course you saw the
famous play where he was about to throw
it and it just popped out of his hand
right and I don't think that's the first
time that's happened to him so yeah that
scares me a little bit would you guess
his hand size I'm gonna say we'll
explain to people what is a normal hand
I mean I think if you got into the Tom
Brady's of the world yes and the Aaron
Rodgers yeah what are they they're like
10 10 and change ten and a half I mean
and what size do you get scared at I get
scared it anybody that's probably around
like a nine and a quarter okay nine and
a half Ryan Tannehill is at nine yeah
that's really small I mean a smaller
Mayfield and all those guys that that
people were complaining about this year
so and look we like to joke about it
because it's like hand-sized how dumb is
that right shoe thing is the true thing
is it's gonna slip out right and then
you look at guys that have monster hands
they never fumble when those blindside
hits right I mean think about all the
time you've seen like Brady Big Ben
Rogers big time wait and you go dim how
the hell did he hold on to the football
there's their fingers wrapping right
I don't know size is a skill Sims Jets
offense dolphins defense just because we
were talking about West Coast often she
wrote
a tight end blocking Robert Quinn a west
coast crime what the foam my gosh it was
a theme if this weekend I saw it in a
few games where I just again they were
going back to what Michael Lombardi said
you know those are things that Bill
Belichick would never do not even with
Rob Gronkowski who I would argue as one
of the greatest blocking tight ends ever
they would never go we want you to go
man-on-man with Kolya Mac or Robert
Quinn no that's not what you are as a
human being on the darn old miss
touchdown pass this is the one that was
in the back of the end zone
you wrote unlucky throwing it away this
happened to me once
yeah what do you mean that sucks I mean
it was actually a I was down there in
Atlanta 2006 the week before I'm gonna
lose my spleen it's the end of the first
half we make a great drive to get down
the field we're losing to Atlanta and
there's like eight seconds left so you
know you have to have a clock in your
head I'm not gonna scramble around like
the Shawn Watson did at the end of the
Tennessee Titans game just wasting all
the time higher so you're thinking like
let me look at one let me lick it to let
me get it out of my hand because I want
to have a chance to kick the field goal
right because they were trying like
there was like eight seconds left so so
so I'm in that mode so here we are and
I'm dropping back and you know I'm about
to throw the ball I'm like mid motion
gonna throw it out of the back of the
end zone and I mean as I'm throwing it
I kill your it is like right there
coming into the screen wide open and I'm
like as I'm doing like oh go down ball
and of course it didn't go down and it
looks like you missed I missed the throw
and you know everybody on the saw my
gosh and no I was really throwing it
away because I was going there's only
two seconds left right now and that's
what happened to Sam darling he was
looking left the play was not supposed
to be over to the right and he's going
dim I'm about to get sacked and I know I
have a throwaway guy over here I'm gonna
throw it over his head well that's a
part of the offense so you know there's
a you know where that guy is at times
yes when you're in the pocket Sam is
doing that in his writing game right
that's good it's special so but I think
the same thing happened to so he's going
I know I got a throwaway spot there I'm
just gonna launch it on the bound and I
think as he's throwing it he's going
wait nobody's [ __ ] covering this guy
and he tried to almost manipulate it
with his hand to get it down but he
couldn't do it and of course then the
points were left on the board it's like
bowling oh I mean you take the
interception in the end zone which I
could show you the play later and if
anybody wants to go on film with the one
two terrelle pryor
yes xavier howard grabbed his right arm
and pulled him and cut in front of him
so how does the knocking I know it's a
shame and then um what was the other one
I was going to say so that was tough
then the other interception he threw it
was just his fault
I mean he's yeah I got the guy kind of
go to defeat him he did he kind of like
faked went with the crosser like it was
yes right it's it's what I do in flight
football yeah yeah but overall though
you think the Dolphins defense is good
your one question is do they have enough
size do they have enough size for a team
that's really gonna try and pound them
right like I love there they're dirt
plethora of defense ends is a modern day
defense they can send waves of pass
rushers at you which is very impressive
and you're like Jordan Phillips I do
like Jordan Phillips and I like Devon
God Shaw and in the middle but you know
as we've talked about with good defenses
you need like four of those guys you
know like New England's got four
yeah you know you know you look at let's
the Baltimore Ravens they got a bunch of
them you know all the good defenses have
those guys to go yes when we got to play
in the mosh pit and and yeah that's just
that's why I'm not worried about the
Ravens long term because I just think
over the course of the season they're
gonna have a bunch of guys left I agree
p-people I think at this time of the
year I always forget people think it's
like a four-game season yeah are you
four and OH guess what man you got 12
more games to go yes then the playoffs
do you have depth because you better
need it cuz they're all gonna get hurt
everybody gets hurt I know all right
Raiders offense Broncos defense talk
about a team that doesn't have depth
from their D line yeah the Raiders
defense let's start on that side of the
ball first and your guy
Phillip Lindsey yeah you're right he's
special he's on another level he can cut
it full speed like the really good ones
can and honestly the Broncos waste too
many carries with the other guys they do
hoist Freeman right and Devante Booker
right I mean I just
there was plays out there and Royce
Freeman's a nice player and he should be
that guy that comes in and spells him
but you know instead of Lindsay getting
different offense with Lindsay it is and
instead of getting Lindsay 14 carries
from 107 you know that Freeman got eight
and Booker got three no I mean Lindsay
needs to get he needs to get 20 touches
at least and then you just don't even
give the other guys care yeah I mean I
wouldn't worry about it he's young in
his career I end but John Elway came
after the draft and said that Roy
screaming to be a Belka that's exactly
what bothers me I mean just come on and
John is usually not that way and I hope
it'll continue to go there so your hope
is that Vance Joseph puts on the film
and goes I let's just do it right now
right what it was just a just what are
we waiting for it it's made by same
argument with the Washington Redskins
and Chris Thompson like what the hell
are you doing he's the best running back
you have but you give him the ball
significantly less than Adrian Peterson
Adrian's nice don't get me wrong but he
is not Chris Thompson at this point of
his career Lindsey can do special things
and some of those runs he made and the
cuts he made at the speed he was going
like only the really good running backs
in football that long run he had what I
always like to see is when you jump yes
and then when you hit the ground and
you're still at the same like if you
even think about that like just go to a
gym go on your streak go on 18
18th Street and then jump and then see
if you can keep running right it's wild
it's why you know he reminds me of how
Roy Helu faster yeah it's a similar
style it may be it's the hair it's
probably there but no I mean using this
kids special I do is he even exceeding
the the things that you saw yes yeah I
didn't think he's a little bit more
better like contact balance that I
wasn't sure then we didn't really get to
see a lot of that in the preseason yeah
but yeah between that and then just the
fearless style in which he runs I mean
holy cow but yeah I just think you got
to get him on the field too because when
he's in the backfield and Denver is not
afraid to be aggressive if they put him
in the backfield and do play-action
passes to him he's the kind of running
back to the defense is you know holy
[ __ ] we got to get to our run gaps oh my
gosh Emmanuel Sanders is behind us for
25 play actually you had two notes on
the Broncos offense that made me in the
green room go WOW and they'll wonder
riously type I don't know what the other
one is but first one is gonna be you did
comment the Demaryius Thomas seems to
drop a big ball every game and you wrote
later Broncos Courtland Sutton is the
second best wide receiver on the team he
is so you would go Sanders Sutton to
Mary I would I would I had no question
about already yeah
Sutton's shut-ins shown me enough in the
preseason these last two games to where
he's a mismatch on the outside he can
run by you and then of course because of
his big body he can go up and catch
footballs listen he was a it looked like
it was a touchdown and they thought his
foot dragged in the outside thought it
was a touch there was another big throw
down the left left sideline another
incredible catch I thought that about it
was it as about out of bounds I need to
see the TV copy of that I remember
watching the game live yeah first one I
thought was a touchdown but his foot
kind of came up and I can understand it
was originally called incomplete right
get it right the second one wasn't as
close but it still made you go Dan this
kid can catch anything he can and he's
and you're right
Demaryius huge drop at the end of the
game huge drop in the end of the game
there the one really big drop earlier
right exactly right of his whole career
it is so but you're why are you
overreacting
I don't think I am I think I think hey
this kid was drafted in the second round
for
reason and was talked about your top
five yes you're talking about being a
late first round guy and I think Denver
drafted him thinking like man Demaryius
has been a little unreliable and we need
another guy here to be a part of this
offense and I think that's why he is
there I think this will be Demaryius
Thomas is I'd have to look at spot track
and look at his contract and all that
but I would bet you this is last year as
a differe Brian you think and what do
you think about Emanuel Sanders these
days Emanuel Sanders is mr. du wall I
mean he could just do everything he's
not as quite as fast as he once was but
he's still really fast to scare the crap
out of defenders the ball in his hands
it is scary and he's are just an out of
this world or outrun her too so yeah
that's where he's great all right here's
the big I know you wrote keenham so many
big throws he is every bit as good as
Derek Carr if not better yeah I know
I'm not trying to create headlines I'm
just telling you from what I saw last
year and all the big throws and I know
it's not he's not a first-round pick or
a second-round pick and people can't
always get their heads through this you
know again hey Tom Brady was a six round
pick so let's not forget that Russell
Wilson was a third round pick there's
just he's a better thrower this year
than he was last year he needs to maybe
dial it back a little bit of an
aggressiveness because he's already
almost has as many interceptions this
year as he had all of them yeah he's
very aggressive right but man does he
make some big-time throws he's fearless
in the pocket and the one thing I can
say in two games is when they needed a
drive they got a case keenum delivers
every freakin time
yeah so there's something to that and
yes he's every bit as good an athlete as
Derek Carr and his arm is every I would
say he has a stronger on the derrick
karr yeah yeah he might not be quite as
crafty of a thrower and we'll talk about
Derek Carr in a second because we did
get to see the fastball but I need to
continue to see that because that's
what's been missing from his game Wow
yeah so Case Keenum franchise
quarterback yeah I mean we just can't
hate on it we can't hate on him forever
you know I don't know how many games do
we need to see to go oh he led them to
the NFC Championship game I'm not sure
yet
why does everybody else everybody else
were sure about but with him it's not
why because he looks a little small he's
not as handsome maybe as some of the
other quarterbacks
I think what
I think what it is is we forget that
when a quarterback comes in as a second
or a third stringer they're offerin in a
very bad situation yeah they're often
playing for a team that gets their
quarterback hurt so their offensive
lines not that good or the wide
receivers aren't getting open and the
time that we saw him be the starter was
Jeff Fisher's last year with Jared Goff
breathing down his neck even though they
started off three and O or three and one
those first four games that London game
maybe that's what sticks number he threw
like a few pick sixes a few weeks in a
row and then that interception against
the Giants and London were and he was
just laying in columns but also end of
the game he just threw it to the Giants
cornerback sitting in the end zone
sometimes when you're in a national game
yeah and you do some big mess ups and
you're not a highly drafted guy and also
let's just be honest
Case Keenum sounds like a third string
quarterback snip it just does you know
it's just there's Case Keenum I know
so I'm trying not to be biased but right
that's all I'm trying to say and maybe
I'm wrong at the end of the year and
Derek Carr don't I'm not trying to this
is not a knock on Derek Carr it is not
because I still think Derek Carr gonna
be special I'm saying I think that Case
Keenum probably needs to be moved up the
ranking of quarterbacks more than I even
gave him credit for and we just have to
recognize that you did write that we
finally saw that Derek Carr fastball I'd
like to see it more your commentary was
more on the offense yeah Raiders offense
are we still only playing one side of
the field which I know what that meant
so you wrote they need to include more
cross field read write so one side of
the field as part of Gruden's offense
like if you if it's two safeties play
this concept on here if there's one
safety play this concept on the other
side of the football cuz you're trying
to attack something right but that's
kind of old-school thinking okay so that
was like prevailing notion before yeah
it was very prevailing notion and a lot
of teams did that back in those days all
right so then when did that start to
change well I think that really New
England is the one that started to
change that where because Belichick was
like why are we hampering ourselves to
one side of the field so is crossing us
so let's just read this guy one
matter what every time who cares if it's
like this coverage of that coverage
he might be open against all coverages
and we've passed up a completion just
because we said this is one safety and
we can only work on this side and to say
so I think New England is the one that
started to go No
and Brady would go let me look at Deion
Branch still left oh that's not it not
even close it's almost like a half a
read where he gets the ball right away
and goes oh that's not there but him
looking over there manipulates the
defense and now that he comes across the
middle to let's say a tight end over the
middle Ben Watson back in the day right
and it's goes okay now Ben Watson's over
the middle oh they got him but then
there's another guy coming into my
vision too as my third read and you've
gone across the board and I think that's
we have that scares me with Gruden a
little bit especially when he gets in
two by two sets any two by two six
you're talking to running back to
tighten more of like two receivers a
tight end and a receiver to the right
and two receivers to the left so when
they're split even so this is something
for us to watch we're watching Raiders
games if we see an even two by two two
receivers are left two receivers to the
right we're thinking that car is only
gonna focus on one side of the field
that's yes it's gonna go one that is the
deal down to the back one you know so
he's gonna go oh I have so many freakin
dumped up exactly right so you're
telling me that if it in Gruden offense
it's two by two whichever side he looks
at first the defense can just start
truck in that way yes and it's not up
and that doesn't kept for play-action
play actions not the same time I'm
talking about drop back pass off you're
telling me though Gruden's not one of
those guys that's gonna know that and
then go let's look that way and then go
to the other side yeah I mean no he's
not it's yeah those are the things that
scare me a little bit about crude and
ran you had an ultimate Sims ISM in your
notes from okay
your quarterback went 29 of 32 and you
scored 19 points
whoopty [ __ ] do this eight 2001 game
is about explosive plays not completion
percentage yes I mean that's what the
game is now let's think of the Rams
let's think of the Saints let's think of
the Patriots let's think of Jacksonville
this weekend taking shots shots
aggressive plays the team that went one
of the most biggest stats in
differentiating of winning and losing a
game other than the
over battle right that's the number one
thing that dick takes a football game
the second most important stat that
dictates the waves over 20 yards exactly
right explosive plays when you break it
down that is the second most important
staff about the Buccaneers sorry oh no
and they've got six touchdowns over 34
you think about the Denver Broncos it
wasn't always pretty but when they
needed it BAM explosive play exposed to
play explosive play and yeah yeah 29 to
32 is great derrick karr made a lot of
great throws but damn it's a lot of work
every time they go down the field and
you wrote how many wide receiver screens
right it's just the same thing it just
you know what it is it's freaking Rich
Gannon so I know that's what I'm saying
that's why I was saying 2001 but that
was cool then the league was different
and roll the clock and and in Gruden had
schemes and that the league hadn't
caught on to so he could be surgical all
the way down the field but now all those
schemes and like Mike Vardy said the
game is so detailed and there's so many
schemes and you have to be all over it
yeah the details of it and so yeah it's
also advanced in terms of film and like
diagnosing simples
yeah right I mean not only your team's
doing their own breakdowns and computus
they're also I'll have they also have
contracts with PFF and things like that
so they're getting their breakdowns too
they're getting everything they need
different technology in the NFL
compared to 2001 and what you're able to
get on a week to week basis yes you're
not you're not asking for game film to
be shipped out from Mount Laurel New
Jersey right just to kind of wrap it up
you said I don't think Gruden's changed
his red zone offense yeah I don't so you
came away from this game in a great
derrick karr performance a historic game
and went god damn it yeah runes offense
is 17 years old still it's just not as
quite as inventive as I would have liked
to have seen you did though positive
you're damn kolache Oh simile is so good
he's one of my favorite watches in the
NFL so take me when you're watching film
and you check out Colette Co semele what
is it like to watch him on film he's my
garden he's like a Fletcher Cox on
defense office yeah but oh yeah exactly
right he's just like he plays with such
passion and such joy out of just
absolutely planting some
in the ground and then planting his head
into that guy what does Roy look like on
film Joey looks and then he gets up and
he like he'll yell not in the direction
of the player but you see like this
movement you know flexing in the arms
because he's going because he just feels
good about it but it's just pedal to the
metal
annihilation never ever and never a
playoff and he might lose a play here
and there because he tries to annihilate
everybody but man is he we're talking
about like a punch annihilation a punch
and then if he gets ahold to you he is
not going to stop driving his legs until
you're on the ground and he can plant
you in it or the whistle blows I mean
that's it he's just not gonna stop yeah
but you did come away very impressed
with the Broncos front seven yeah I mean
the Broncos like they have it all
there's another front seven I look at
anything greater than what we said about
the Jets where there's never gonna be a
mismatch because if they want to play
big boy football they can do it and then
man when you got Shane ray and Shaquille
Barrett coming off the bench off the
edge man that's when you know you're
pretty damn sacked let's go or Shaun
looked awesome - let me just say you did
Marshawn you're not a big fan of Doug
Martin I don't see the Doug Martin
Marshawn Lynch still has I just Marshawn
can still make things happen that are
not there to be had oh [ __ ] the whole
plays ruined on the left I'm pretty sure
the Raiders play the Dolphins so that's
what's interesting it'll be interesting
because you just said you're not sure
about the Dolphins about a good running
team here comes that interior line with
Marshawn behind them and the and I I'm
not gonna sit here and hate on the
tackles for all the way better they were
better so we're gonna see a little test
of the dolphin we definitely will it's
down in Miami right I think it's an East
Coast trip for the think so yeah that's
a thing
Oakland's gotta go to Denver and then
come back across to my hand go hot Miami
they're not gonna be ready for that
humidity that's gonna be tough playing
in Miami this time of the year is no
joke
Colts offense Washington defense yeah
this is when you watch with no notes for
me so I don't know yeah but I really
just want to know where are we with
Andrew Luck where we're at the place
with Andrew Luck where again the stat
line is not gonna be special and there
was some big there was some big pass
interferences right that got called the
Redskins had seven penalties for 90
yards things like that but they were
because Andrew Luck was gonna throw
balls down the field
on the screws and they were like oh [ __ ]
we better tackle tu I held in there this
is gonna be a huge gain so he's back to
taking some shots he his ability to
throw the ball down the field with the
explosive plays that are there be had
he's just on the screws almost always
now he threw one dumb interception down
the middle of field he was under duress
and DJ swearing Joe got him the other
interception the ball got tipped to the
line of scrimmage does he just married a
dove and caught it it was great but the
thing with Andrew Luck is when he gets
close to the red zone his aggressive
mind sets the difference of the game it
really is because as we talked about
with a lot of these teams he makes you
to defend the whole field and he's not
there for his completion percentage he's
there to win football games and he knows
to win football games damn if that
25-yard out routes there I'm gonna drop
back hit my seventh step and let it go
because I think there's a chance and it
puts fear into defenses and it changes
the game and then when he gets down in
the red zone yes
Oh naheem Hines for 8 yards up the
middle well do because they're worried
about Andrew Luck yeah he's gonna take a
shot into the end zone he should throw
another back shoulder to Eric Ebron
that's gonna be right on the money
forking he bro that's what I mean here I
mean you were right about that he didn't
know if he bran would be able to turn
himself around from Detroit I have found
a role that bad in Detroit I think that
he was in an offense in Detroit that
loves three wide receivers in the field
and they should because they got gala
day and they got Golden Tate and they
got Marvin Jones yeah I get it right but
when you're in a Frank Reich offense
that loves tight ends going across the
middle and he's out there with Jack
Doyle and he doesn't have to block all
the time even though Martellus Bennett
said he hates those guys he's a weapon
for a guy like Andrew Luck his luck has
always loved the tight end position he
does hey there ebrill is is a step
faster than Jack Doyle
he definitely is their old line can
protect I know what you think about the
old line I mean I think the OL lankan
it's on the right track to being able to
be one of the best protecting Eliza
Nelson he's looking good what do they
call babyface babyface Nelson the
gangster I just think and they don't
even have Costanzo back no I know I know
and and you know the culture a team that
could be scared I know they can be scary
there was one other point I wanted to
make about what just the big thing is
one of the themes of the weekend was
teams that kick filos lost and teams
that scored touchdowns one and this game
would be the perfect example
oh yeah the Redskins were great at going
up and down the field three field goals
for dust oh that's amazing great but you
know it's a game about explosive plays
and scoring so how many times in New
England we talked that team kicks a
field goal Tom goes down and scores a
touchdown those are those are jubilant
Texas patriots case exactly um
Washington defense they're gonna be okay
Washington defense is going to be okay
how's our D line doing it's it's good
they didn't like dominate the football
game but you know again I'm gonna get
Frank write some credit too he doesn't
let you always just tee off he gives you
different looks he gets sidelines runs
like the Eagles do where he gets those
Center and guard pulling out his face
doing those type of things to where he
doesn't let a you don't get settled in
what they're doing you don't get a
Jonathan Allen and our other guy legs an
ass damn I'm blanking on his name what
the hell's this frickin name our man
durante yeah to where they can just go
I'm going up field all game long yes
you're going I'm gonna go feel about the
same time they might gonna left oh and
they moved random Andrew Luck in it just
and he keeps you on edge that way you
came away from the Colts defense blown
away at the sudden surplus of studs that
they have and you wrote WTF ballard
effect yeah it's just this is why he is
a special crisp allergy special event of
talent it's okay so listen and the
preseason I was very concerned the
everybody was I mean it's it's a lot of
guys I don't know about it didn't always
look good in the preseason there's a lot
of young guys so that's what was scary
added to the fact that you know teams
don't always do what they're really
gonna do on defense in the preseason
sometimes they keep it simple elbow I
can't say his last name is ever flus
member flus what he is doing is running
the Dallas defense aka a little bit of
the Seattle defense right bit so it's
very similar in traits there which means
you need at Letta climb backers
defensive linemen they get up the field
right and longer secondary guys to SWAT
it all that so they got they got corners
on the outside that yeah man
man they're not gonna be anything
special do those corner names I don't
even know I know but the amount of
hidden gems he has found that are in
Ricky's or in your - it's just
astounding run him off what he is done
I'm so first we got to start off with
Darius Leonard he goes by the maniac and
he had 18 tackles against Washington I
mean and you were not sure about him at
South Carolina definitely was not
because I did not think he dominated at
the level of which he was being talked
about and of course at South Carolina
stadia I worried it some of the talent
he was down there I was like damn that's
it that's that's having a left go
playing left guard I don't know what to
think about it you know what I mean it
must be great yeah but he he is a freak
Joe he's a freak show he's just a
reckless abandon he's at Alvin Smith a
Ryan shazier but he's got a little more
size in both of those guys you know
maybe a Bobby Wagner Myles Jack I'm not
gonna put him in miles jack athletic
class I mean but if you're saying some
serious guy but everywhere he is
everywhere and he just has a knack to
avoid blockers and still get through and
makes it a goal right all those kind of
things that you hear yeah he holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] and then the other guy next to
Anthony Walker is similar who's this kid
Anthony Walker what the hell is this
school I gotta just look it up again
it's California Pennsylvania yeah no no
that's the that's that's the key the
safety from Oakland we didn't get to him
oh yeah we didn't get to him Anthony
Walker is a northwestern kid okay
Oh safety from Oakland by the way is
Eric Harris number you are very
impressed with him he's six 3225 number
25 watch him Raiders fans you'll like
him but Anthony Walker I'm not gonna lie
I didn't know a whole lot about this guy
at all I mean never heard I don't know
he's died deep into the sixth and
seventh round picks like that but he's
similar in stature same type of guy 6 1
2 42 can really run not up to Darius
Leonard stays but and this type of
defense where that athletic linebacker
is so crucial yeah yeah they're they're
everywhere and they're awesome in the
past game and then sideline to sideline
it's the real deal - and you think this
Marcus hunt kid pops - man Marcus hunt
is like he's reborn uh you know they're
I mean you know he's the marques hunt as
the guy that came from the Cincinnati
Bengals oh yeah right yeah I mean he was
the first round I think he was a
first-round pick out of
some you my right am I don't remember I
totally crazy yeah Southern Methodist
okay I know I haven't smoked a whole lot
of weed lately and I feel like my brains
getting stupider because of it is that
the thing might be I mean I really feel
like I'm the less I smoked that dumber
I'm getting well there's a lot of
theories that if you learn something
when you're in that state you have to be
in that state to remember okay so maybe
you were just watching a lot of film
this offseason in a certain state so I
don't do that though I usually don't
like doing that I'm not that kind of guy
watching the same play 45 you're like I
just can't remember but then yes Marcus
hunt he's taking over the Tyrone
Crawford role for the Dallas Cowboys
right the strong side defensive end
defense and D tackle when we gotta get
small and do that and he could be people
but he was all over the field too sorry
oh so no no no yeah so the Colts overall
you like what they got going on yeah I
really do like what they got to going on
men the guy in the middle 90 Grover
Street 6-4 333 Albany state from Georgia
Albany State Georgia I mean that this is
why I'm giving I want to give Chris
Ballard credit it's it's not household
names but he has found these guys that
have great value and he knows the look
of what he wants at certain positions
yeah and this is what great GM's do so
it's really uh it's it's a testament to
him and what he's done
Jets Browns is going to be the Thursday
night game immanuel agua and Christian
Kirksey may miss the game last year
Browns played the Jets Browns really
dominated the game had three sacks eight
quarterback hits and the Jets only had
212 yards but their offense had two
first half turnovers inside the 5-yard
line and they missed two field goals
before half-time and as the Browns were
one to do last year the Jets ended up
winning that game Browns are gonna be
wearing they're all brown color rush
uniforms Oh baby pinch me maybe and I'm
sure you guys watch Sims and left go the
show last night where alley white our
new Oracle has gone eagles bengals
back-to-back two and oh and he's picking
the Jets to win this game outright in
Cleveland
as your kind of feeling it what is your
take for the game for Thursday night
gosh
Thursday night is so freaking hard I
know I really I don't know what to do on
Thursday I want to pick the home team
every time Browns at home sounds good
but I will say this is a tweet from Evan
Silva and d-boy oh I agree
only the Browns would force their kicker
to kick through a groin injury allow it
to cost them two wins cut the kicker and
then replace him with one who has never
kicked in the NFL and made just 69 point
five percent of his career field goal
attempts in college but I'm just saying
that could be the difference on Thursday
night because I don't think the Browns
offense is gonna push around the Jets
especially without a guy like Josh
anymore I agree I don't I don't like do
you really think that Jarvis Landry is
gonna get that open against Tremayne
Johnson and those guys tremaine's gonna
eat him alive
I mean that's secondary the Jets is the
real is maybe one of the best of the end
of the venture main screen and Claiborne
Carlos Hyde is not gonna push over this
D line I don't think so either so it's
really gonna come down to yes Greg
Williams defense versus Sam Darnell
exactly right and I I wanna I want to
take the Jets I think the Jets are the
better football team
Tyrod Taylor at home is a much better
player than Tyrod Taylor on the road yes
not gonna turn the ball over and it's
gonna play it safe right it's just Sam
d'Arles it's quincy anoon were gonna get
open all those times Ryan it's the brown
I like what Jeremy Bates is doing on
that defensive side of them I mean
offenses out of the ball what do you
think Sam Donald short week rookie
season i those are the things that scare
me I want who did I pick on the show yes
it screw you Ali I'm picking the brown
right cuz I wanted to just be opposite
Ali and I'm just I'm scared if you're
just obsessed that he's took your
nickname you're scared that I am picking
the away team that's actually what it
comes down to it's and and you know what
we've had two home team's win I know so
I guess if you made a put a gun to my
head so you don't feel this would be a
$10 bet and our betting show on
definitely have you put a gun to my head
I'm gonna take the Browns even though I
think the Jets are better just it's it
makes sense you know again team
team has to travel on a Wednesday and it
takes away from one extra walkthrough
another group of meetings that Cleveland
will get things like that and that's
where it's it and of course hey it's
your taking away time of guys being
creative with their game plans too and
what they could do there Todd Bowles can
be pretty creative on defense and Jeremy
Bates could be pretty creative Williams
yeah he can - he can - I don't think
he's as good coverage wise as Todd
Bowles uh just to note the Browns will
be wearing they're all brown color Rush
uniform you know you just you've said
that already good I just wanted to
really because I'm super excited about
the all Brown look-alike bunch of turd
mr. Hankey's running around when you're
supposed to tie a button that top button
would he didn't want me to I'll do it
for the if what he said wear a poop
emoji on your head would you do it I
mean if she told me that it's popping
right now I know you would you would you
know why cuz I just don't like to think
about it I'm like Elon Musk I'm like
Mark Zuckerberg just clothe me I have
bigger things to fry is that what he
says I don't know okay this is a we're
gonna hit it here this is from Zach one
Fitzgerald okay he's got an NN and if L
for sins we didn't we didn't get into
Falcons Panthers I know you didn't get a
chance to read my notes I didn't do you
want to do it real quick or do you not
really care here's the synopsis really
quick okay the Falcons offense the red
zone problems are not over so even
though they scored on every red zone
trip against Carolina for timeout line
it just came out man-to-man defense and
let the Falcons run some really simple
realm they really did so I didn't sister
go oh gosh what this is they finally
have done something creative no yeah
Carolina's panicked when they couldn't
stop the run game and they played man a
few times so you had the Calvin Ridley
11 yard touchdown pass it was a slant
route it was a slant and a flat and they
played man-to-man with a touchdown
Austin Hooper I don't know again it was
an eight yard touchdown pass Matt Ryan
played awesome in the game he made a lot
of big-time throws but again Carolina
and was playing man-to-man I don't know
why they usually don't do that but I do
think it was because they were getting
gash in the run game then there was the
Matt Ryan one-yard run which was a
quarterback sneak and
kind of ran it down in there to get that
and then there was the Matt Brian
scramble for eight yards which was a
great like helicopter John Elway's I
dive right right it was cool I mean he
got balls I'll give him that
and they but Carolina was all over that
they played their normal zone red zone
defense and Matt Ryan did what he's
supposed to do when you make 30 million
dollars a year and he made a play
sacrificers and that was that was
awesome so that is it and then on the
defensive side of the ball yeah how did
they do without Keyon O'Neill and Deon
Jones right Duke Riley is the other guy
that's gonna question LSU kid very
athletic
a little undersized a linebacker you
linebacker right well he's the new deal
his job he is and he's like the same
size as key an O'Neill so this is not
like a big guy right okay and then
instead of Keon O'Neill or Hera lino
doesn't really have a power running game
no it's more dumped off to McCaffrey as
much as possible and yet Duke Riley 6 1
to 30 I would challenge whether he's 230
ok but what they didn't set of the
safety down in the box they let Ricardo
Allen be that guy Ricardo balanced to be
Earl Thomas on the back end oh but they
probably know they didn't want to trust
some of the other guys down there
there's a lot of rules that you have to
know he's been in that defense for a
while they put him there for Cordova
Islands a very good player he's not
gonna be able to be thumper like a can't
on Neal
but it's good enough to make do now the
other safety
hey Demonte cozy all that I don't like
him for the cheap shot I'm either yeah
I'm he's not a guy I'm rooting for but
either way
Carroll they played smart what there is
nothing to worry about
DJ more has to get on the field for the
Carolina Panthers I don't know what the
deal is he gets in and he pops on film
you saw the 51-yard touchdown he had
these the only guy that can do that they
don't have you don't think Funches can
do that you don't think Darius Wright
can do that none of them can no none of
them could do that and in Atlanta was
smart too to where they didn't play
man-to-man a whole lot they played and
that's why McCaffrey had such a big day
they dropped back to but that's what
they always do yes if you look the
Falcons allow the most receiving yards
two running back like the whole lot of
thigh I could see it as their whole
defense is oh yeah catch underneath and
then a rally last linebackers are gonna
change it yeah yes sir they really are
and especially against the Carolina type
team who they don't have this intricate
really detailed short passing
- so you err on that because what's the
one thing we know cam can launch it camp
could throw back shoulders - Devin
Funchess down the field
why give Devin Funchess the chance to
just go one-on-one and beast people so
it was a McCaffrey day but they need
another guy that can do things that
aren't always drawn up perfectly on the
chalkboard they play the Saints this
week Oh Alvin Kamara underneath have fun
chasing him yeah have fun man can played
really good can't play good and cams
running cams the team right now again
yes and that's the shame without Greg
Olson yep
you know McCaffrey is solid player good
don't get me wrong but the game is still
going through cam and they're beat up on
the old line Grady Jarrett whooped ass
that was my he's a baller
alright so Zack Fitzgerald and n if L so
it's a it's a hypothetical situation for
you got you okay so take your mind back
close your eyes and we're going back to
2003 it's day two of draft night Sims is
sitting next to the big [ __ ] waiting
to get draft I did he piss too and he
gets a call from a Dallas area code he
answers it's Bill Parcells how you doing
little [ __ ]
the Cowboys draft Sims number 38 overall
so it's day 1 of the draft yeah number
38 overall second rounder fast forward a
training camp and Sims is battling it
out with Quincy Carter
Parcells bunk Sims with Carter Sims you
look like a ball and tallgrass lost
fast-forward to today
Sims has five Super Bowls and Aaron
Rodgers is doing a podcast with Lefko
after suffering a career-ending spleen
injury they praised Sims as the greatest
quarterback of all time so my question
is if Sims have been drafted by his
dad's old coach where does he think his
career would have went oh that would
have been awesome I'll say that much
I mean I've wanted to play for the
Dallas Cowboys did you well my dad
retired Troy Aikman was my favorite of
course quarterback and two of his old
coach there yep and of course yes Bill
Parcells is is
special and I mean that year they but
they took Tony Romo right later in the
draft or maybe he's off or was he I
don't think he was in your next year
yeah check that out I can't even
remember anymore hey that would be
really amazing I don't know about the
Aaron Rodgers part because Aaron Rodgers
would still be in Green Bay and it has
nothing to do with any of this but
there's a lot of what-ifs I could play
in that that's an area man I still think
about one left 2003 I was yeah what if I
didn't throw three interceptions in the
big 12 championship game my junior year
in college I was thinking teams were
telling me I was going to be a top 10
pick
I was thinking damn I'm I might have to
leave for the NFL Draft after my junior
year that's where I was thinking that I
threw three picks and the big ball
Championship never like yeah we don't
even want to draft you anymore forget it
so there is a lot of what-ifs they're
always in your career hey my career
happened for a reason I don't know why
god er powers-that-be took my spleen but
it is what it is and I get the great
gift of being with you every day and
that's the perfect way to ended
oh thanks Zach Fitzgerald good question
alright that was our notebook again to
all the teams and fans that we didn't
get to we will go detailed tomorrow in
our pick show can't believe we're back
at it again Thursday having to make the
picks we'll have the official numbers of
the money that we lost and the money
that we want to know yet at all I
haven't looked I don't want to look at
it would depress me too much so for
everyone out there we will do the picks
tomorrow again if you haven't checked it
out go to youtube check out Sims and
Lefko the show it's a new episode and
it's packed with Melvin Gordon Melvin
Ingram and and again we need your hash
tags on Sunday hashtag sack face its
pictures of the quarterback and what
their faces look like after they got hit
inspired by Eli Manning for sense peace
out homey Kendrick would say good
evening and for the lef koe man holla
holla holla holla to our podcast for
your homies Sam joy